So, schauen wir mal ob es jetzt besser funktioniert.
So, mal gucken ob das jetzt besser klappt.
Aaaah, ja aaah, guck mal da, meine Vorschau funktioniert, meine Vorschau funktioniert.
Wahnsinn.
Ich weiß nicht was da, komisch, ich meine ihr habt es ja alles gesehen, ich meine ich
habe auch nur einen ganz normalen Browser, also die müsste eigentlich auch so funktionieren,
aber ok.
Na gut, dann können wir jetzt ja anfangen.
Haskill stream, na gab's nicht, weg, Alter, wir haben schon Kobold gemacht, das sollte
reichen.
Ok, also was ich jetzt machen will, wie gesagt ich habe mir ein Tutorial angeguckt, was ich
jetzt machen will, wir ignorieren mal diesen ganzen Blödsinn, den ich hier gemacht habe,
und den ganzen Graben kopieren wir auch mal hier rein, und ja ja, das bleibt jetzt erstmal
so wie es ist.
Also, was ich gerne machen möchte ist sowas da, guck mal, api gleich, alert manager,
ja ja, so ungefähr, new, und dann will ich sowas haben wie localhosts, so, so, geh mal
weg, Ryder, so will ich das, so will ich das constructen, ja, aber, nee, so will ich das
nicht constructen, so, so, so will ich das constructen, funktioniert nicht, oder sollte
man das jetzt besser klein machen, Leute, was ist denn convention, sagt mal, muss das
Package, sollte das Package groß sein, oder sollte das Package klein sein, der Typ, der
Typ sollte auf jeden Fall, ok, dann sollte der Ordner also auch klein sein, geh ich mal
von aus, so, aber der Typ muss auf jeden Fall groß sein, also ich will, also ich will sowas
hier machen, new, so, das habe ich nämlich gesehen in diesem YouTube Tutorial, wie das
funktioniert, und zwar, guck mal, ob ich das jetzt noch hinkriege, so, also, function,
weil das das das blöde ist, ja, in.net, ich mach mal kurz Ryder auf, so, mal so zum
Vergleich, ja, postchamp.cs, jawoll, dadurch den Stream neustart einfach 60 Zuschauer
rausgeschmissen, in.net kannst du ja sowas hier machen, ja, aber zum Beispiel public
class silence, und wenn ich jetzt einen Constructor anlegen will, weil ich sagen muss, hey, in
dieser Klasse muss unbedingt eine ID angegeben werden, das ist Pflicht, dann würde ich
sowas hier so machen, ja, ID, ID gleich ID und fertig, sowas gibt es in Go nicht, was
man wohl in Go machen kann, wenn ich das, wenn ich das in diesem Tutorial Video richtig
gesehen habe, ist sowas, ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das, ob das stimmt, was ich hier als, als
Syntax fabrizieren, ne, also man kann irgendwie sagen New, Factory, genau, man kann irgendwie
sagen New und dann muss man irgendwie sagen, Alert Manager RP, Return, URL, irgendwie so,
so, dann braucht man hier den Parameter, so, irgendwie so, und jetzt kann ich angeblich,
ja, stimmt doch, und jetzt funktioniert das, und jetzt funktioniert das, und jetzt kann
ich Alert Manager RP New sagen und dann kriege ich ein neues Alert Manager RP Objekt, genau,
habe ich das, habe ich zur Abwechslung mal in diesem Tutorial Video aufgepasst, natürlich
ist das jetzt reichlich sinnlos, wenn man wirklich bloß die URL hat, das kann ich ja
auch hier oben reinschreiben, ich würde gerade sagen, Most advanced struct an der Zeit,
dafür brauchst du ja noch nicht mal den struct theoretisch, aber ok, so, und jetzt kann man,
und jetzt kann man, wenn man das mit dem New mal außen, außen vor lässt, und jetzt kann
man, wenn man API Punkt macht, kann man da irgendwie auch Methoden drauf registrieren,
da weiß ich aber die, die Sündtags nicht, kann das Rider für mich machen, nee, Moment,
Generate Constructor, ach, guckt mal, Rider kann mir den Campbell sogar automatisch generaten,
keck weh, easy, dann nehmen wir doch das, was Rider generated hat, ob das jetzt schöner
ist als meins weiß ich ja auch nicht, ich bleib bei meinem, allein schon weil es selbst
gemacht ist, wo ist eigentlich der Sinn davon, dass einmal als Pointer, warum soll ich das
als Pointer returnen, keine Ahnung, ist das Fiveheadiger mit Pointer Leute, ist das irgendwie
High IQ mit Pointer, und ohne Pointer ist es Low Brain, Low Bob Gehirn, oder wie, ups,
falsch, oder wie ist das, so, zumindest kann man jetzt, das weiß ich aber nicht, ob ich
die Sündtags hin krieg, guck mal, Fivehead, Fivehead Go Land, Fivehead Go Land Autocomplete,
das hab ich gesucht, weil jetzt kann man sowas sagen wie Get Silences, und jetzt kann ich
wenn alles funktioniert sagen AP Punkt, und dann hab ich auf diesem Objekt ne Methode drauf,
Go Land ist Massive, 180 EQ das Ding, weil ich hätte im Leben mir diese Sündtags hier
nicht merken können, was ist das überhaupt für ne komische Sündtags, das sieht ein bisschen
aus wie.NET Extension Methods, ohne Extension Methods zu sein, wisst ihr was das ist, das
ist C++ Header Files Style fast schon, also kein wirklicher Header, in C++ wollen die
Leute nämlich auch nicht, dass man Methoden und sowas inline schreibt, sondern unten
drunter, das find ich aber hässlich, war das jetzt zu viel verlangt sowas zu haben, oder
wie, das, ich mein, das wär doch irgendwie cooler, aber das wollten die, wollten die
Go Leute anscheinend nicht, wäre zu, zu Obvious gewesen, was, Redo is Ctrl Shift Z, das kann
ich mir doch im Leben nicht merken, das muss ich, das muss ich, das muss ich ändern, Shortcuts,
Keymaps, ja, ja, hier, Redo, Redo, ach nee, Ctrl Y hat er schon remapped, ok, alles klar,
da hab ich nichts gesagt, also kann ich jetzt, ok, passt, so, also Get Silences, ich möchte
jetzt alle Silences, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, dann halt ohne Rider
heute, ich hab mich ausgelockt über mein, mein Toolbox Account, aber Golan scheint es
nicht zu interessieren, das ist erstmal egal, Rider Gag Buy, ja, ja Rider, machs gut, heute
nicht, so, also wir sind verstehen geblieben, ok, das kommt raus, so, Get Silences, ok, alles
klar, und jetzt muss ich diesen Krempel, den ich hier irgendwo eingebaut habe, nee, den
ich noch gar nirgends wo eingebaut habe, ach das hab ich noch nirgendswo gemacht, muss
ich da jetzt rein basteln, also sprich, wir können uns noch mal die Swagger API davon
angucken von diesem Ding, sprich das da, das da wollen wir jetzt machen, Get Silences,
das ist die Response, wisst ihr was, wir benutzen einfach mal wieder die High IQ Generierung
von Golan, Silence, das hatten wir doch schon mal, Matchers, dann nehmen wir das anstelle
von dem hier, das ist richtig geil, dass der Swagger Jason zu Go Classes machen kann, richtig
High IQ Kram, so, ok, jetzt wirds Go technisch spannend, also ich will ein Get machen, ich
will ein Get machen, allerdings will ich Filtern können nach Hostname, also machen wir mal
sowas hier, sowas wie Query Filter String, und jetzt ist die Frage, wie machen wir Query
Filter String nach Hostname Hoggers, keine Ahnung, ich muss mal kurz in mein Alertmanager
etwas anlegen, ist nicht gestartet, ok, moin, falls einer der Monster ist, könnt ihr mal
please das Daily Projekt heute aktualisieren, Mensch, Alertmanager, geh auf, also Silences,
Silence, Add, New Silence, gegen den Müll eintragen, Hostname gleich, Hoggers, Create,
was ist das Problem, achso, man muss das Quoten, ok, das Webinterface ist wirklich reine Zumutung,
wobei eigentlich passt der Titel ja immer noch ganz gut, aber man könnte vielleicht
hinschreiben, das machen wir weg, und dahinten heute in Go oder irgendwie sowas, also, wir
müssen jetzt irgendwie gucken, wie man ein Getrequest machen kann, mit Go und dort ein
Filter eingeben, also das Ziel ist folgendes aufzurufen, try out, Moment, wo gibt es nochmal
die Curl Examples hier, so, heute und auch heute mit OOP, genau, so, also das ist natürlich
Blödsinn, wir wollen Local Host, AP, V2, Silences haben, also sprich das hier, sind
da überall Quotes drum herum, Mensch, ja, also das hier wollen wir mit Go machen, diesen
Request, nur dass man hier noch ein Filter eingeben kann, weil man kann das Filter, man
kann nämlich an irgendeiner Stelle sagen, Filter nach, wo steht es denn, hier, Filter,
und da kann man dann verschiedene Sachen hinten angeben, was man irgendwie nicht, Parameter
irgendwie nicht hier mit übergeben kann, kann man irgendwie Parameter einstellen, try
it out, ane hier, add string item, Hostname, Kekl, so, ja, Filter, Hostname, gleich Poggers,
das wollen wir eigentlich haben, Filter, Hostname, gleich Poggers, so, und wo Bezahlung, der Chat
bezahlt euch mit, mit, dass er euch mag, ja, dass alle sagen, wir haben die besten Mods
überhaupt, Chat, einmal Please Mod Check für unsere Mods, die sich so viel Mühe geben,
im Discord, im Chat, überall, einmal Cute Mods, genau, leider ist der Ober Cute Mod
schon eine Weile nicht mehr am Start, von dem habe ich auch schon eine Weile nichts mehr
gehört, keine Ahnung, wo der steckt, genau, Paid in Exposure ist das, siehste, so sieht
es aus, wo der Sebaro steckt, keine Ahnung, warum hast du dich dazu entschlossen Go zu
lernen, weil saumäßig viel in Go programmiert ist und weil ich mal gucken will, was Go so
für Vorteile hat, den einzigen Vorteil, den ich aktuell sehe ist Static Binaries, ansonsten
ehrlich gesagt hält es sich noch in Grenzen die Vorteile, also es ist nicht so, dass ich
sagen würde, Go ist der Giga Chat, die ist die Giga Chat Sprache, also Giga Chat ist
eindeutig C Sharp vorbehalten bisher, wo kommt es denn zum Einsatz, Go, Go ist überall mittlerweile,
gerade was Cloud, wie sagt man so, Cloud Native Software angeht, also so ziemlich alles was
irgendwas mit Infrastructure, Escode, Container, Skalierung, Cloud Gedöns zu tun hat, wenn
es nicht gerade Azure und.NET ist, dann ist es Bin bereit für den C Sharp Stream, wir
haben schon sehr vieles gemacht, also sehr viel, Github, man kann den Github gar nicht
gescheit sortieren nach Sprachen, Flutter haben wir mal gemacht, wer sich daran nicht
mehr erinnern kann, wir haben die beste App der Welt in Flutter programmiert, das macht
uns keiner nach, guckt euch die App an, die App hier, seht ihr das, Massive App, die
Cute App haben wir entwickelt, die nichts machen konnte außer Aja Ja sagen, mit FFmpeg,
so jetzt aber weiter, sonst wird das wieder nix hier, wie mache ich jetzt ein Get Request
ordentlich in Go, mit irgendeinem Url Filter oder so, also HTTP nicht Post, Get, was wollen
wir getten, wir wollen die AP Url, also das ist das, was wir hier oben in dem Struct drin
stehen haben, AP Url plus Silences, dumme Frage, was ist die schönere Variante, Urls
zu Combine in Go, gibt es sowas wie Url, Combine, Join, Pass Query, Unescape Pass, ok da muss
ich Google, Google muss bemüht werden, Join Url Go Lang, Combine Url Pass Join, funktioniert
das, da habe ich so meine Zweifel, dass das klappt, probieren wir mal aus, ob das klappt,
Has, Join, probieren wir das mal aus, wir machen das jetzt ab, bevor jetzt wieder Sixhead
Time im Chat angesagt ist, ich weiß, dass ich den Slash doppelt habe, aber das ist da
gerade der Sinn davon, warum man sowas verwendet, weil die unter anderem solche Fehler abfangen,
ich habe kein Terminal auf, Go Land Projects, Go, ok Run, guck, Broken, Pass Join, funktioniert
nicht, löscht einen Slash aus dem HTTP raus, maybe sowas, ok wenn der Chat das sagt, das
sind Query Parameter und keine Urls, die gejoint werden, oder, ne, das sind Query Parameter,
ne ne, ich will ja die Url zusammenpappen, also ich will da Silences an apv2 hinten dran
machen und für den Fall der Fälle, dass zwei Slashes drin sind, dass der das aufräumt,
aber mit Pass Join scheint, sag mal kann das sein, dass Go sowas nicht hat in der Standard
Library, das kann doch nicht sein, how to build, url, how to join components, add join
pass, url join pass, ja genau, wieso man sowas joinen sollte, naja, dass du keine Slashes
doppelt hast zum Beispiel, close, ja was sonst, anscheinend ist das über dem Niveau oder
unter dem Niveau der Go Standard Library Entwickler sowas einzubauen, alles klar, dann machen
wir halt einfach plus und gut ist, also plus, so, htp get ap url plus silences, so und jetzt
muss ich hinten dran, also das Ziel ist ja, dass wir sowas hier bauen, silences, pilter
gleich, hostname gleich, das muss url encoded werden, poggers, ja, weil so wird das nicht
funktionieren, ich bin gar nicht sicher bin, ob man das encoden muss, aber wir werden sehen,
ja.
Sowas schreibt man schneller selbst, da habe ich meine Zweifel, dass das so einfach ist,
wie du dir das vorstellst, ich denke mal ein korrektes url join, dass das alles richtig
checkt ist gar nicht so einfach, das ist ja nicht, es ist ja nicht so, als müsste man
einfach nur checken, hört das mit slash auf und dann lasst den slash weg, das muss ja
auch solche Sachen händeln, wie steht htp da vor, du musst erstmal alle gültigen Protokolle
kennen, das was da vorstehen kann, ah high iq kappa, ja, ok, hey, das kann man natürlich
wunderbar erkennen an diesem Satz, ohne irgendwas dahinter, da weiß man natürlich obviously,
dass das kapp gemeint war, im net url package, nö, das habe ich doch gerade ausprobiert,
das ist nicht, guck hier url, url, was net, punkt url, nö, gibt's gar nicht, gibt noch
immer das package, aber das url package selber, also hier in dieser ul-klasse selber gibt
sowas nicht, ist auch egal, wir bauen das jetzt weiter zusammen, so get, wie kriege
ich ein query string dahin, ich mein, die noob-variante wäre jetzt ja tatsächlich sowas
zu machen, ja, aber das kann ja nun wirklich nicht, escape, also das kann jetzt ja nicht
wirklich sinn und zweckgewollt sein in go, das kanns ja net sein, also das ist ja auch
sehr fehleranfällig, query string hab ich gerade gepaustet, zeig ich mal, das da, copy
address, ok, ah ja, ok, was new request, moment, also kann man nicht direkt in get machen,
es wird advanced da, ich seh schon, also api-url-silences, get, hat go keine enums, dass man hier, muss
man hier wirklich strings reinschreiben, weil ich mein, ich könnt jetzt hier auch cute-chat
als htp-methode reinschreiben und die gibt's ja nicht, ok, error, error, jetzt war wirklich,
wer glaubt denn ernsthaft, dass wir error handling machen, wir machen kein error handling,
so bloated graben kommt mir gar nicht erst in die Tüde, so request, also wie geht das
weiter, das ist halt auch das sinnloseste error handling aller Zeiten, einfach den error
printen, tja, it's ja nicht so als würden exceptions für sowas erfunden, erfunden,
vielleicht gibt es ja sowas, htp, get, ja, viel besser, viel besser so, ok, also was
macht man jetzt, q, gleich, ok, jetzt wird's wir, query, gleich, query, url, add, what,
who encode, was wollen die dudes von mir, alter, das ist ja mal, ok, das ist pepega
hässlich, wer macht denn sowas, ich, ich weiß nicht, also auf der einen Seite wirkt
die go standard library durchdacht und auf der anderen Seite so als hat man die Hälfte
vergessen, ok, api key wollen wir nicht haben, wir wollen haben filter und dann ja query,
query filter oder sowas, sowas in der Richtung, was, so kann man das auch machen, zeig her,
the function path join expects a path, not, ja, das ist mir auch klar, pass url to get
pass and join, was, rede mit, das ist jetzt nicht sein Ernst oder, url pass, pass join,
das ist so wir, ich versteh doch nicht mal, was es macht, ah, doch, was in der standard
library, zeig mal her, was, example, nee, was, und was soll es da geben, join, da ist
kein join drin, aber hier unten stand doch irgendwas, url, ja in go 1.1, 9 ist das drin,
das gibt es aber noch nicht, ok, das ist hardcore umständlich, was haben wir noch, use resolve
reference, alter ist das kompliziert, meine Güte, ich will einfach den url zusammen
joinen, dann mach ichs lieber so, dann ist im zweifelsfall halt die url kaputt, aber
das passiert nichts schlimmes, ok, so, jetzt hab ich ein query, jetzt hab ich ein query-filter
hinten dran, ok, alles klar, und wie sende ich das jetzt ab, request send oder sowas,
ne, anscheinend nicht, alter ich bin doch nicht mal in der lage in go und ordentlichen
http-request zu machen, content-type, content-type kann ich auch nicht, muss ich wirklich ein
header selbst setzen für content-type, wie ist denn das, content-type, so, dann bin ich
mir gar nicht sicher, ob das so funktioniert, nächsten monat, go 1.1, 9, ja die haben noch
einiges vor sich, wenn sowas wie url-join noch nicht in der standard-library drin ist,
ich glaube, ok, wir machen jetzt den ultimativen test, hat das c++ in der standard-library,
ach ich will gar nicht in just chatting sein, du hast recht, ich will in software und spiele-entwicklung
will ich sein, warum man go bevorzugen würde, ganz ehrlich, keine ahnung, mir fällt nur
ein grund ein, mir fällt wirklich nur ein grund ein, und das ist, weil es gut static
libraries baut, die überall drauf laufen, parsi, dankeschön für den sub, was anderes
fällt mir nicht ein, weiß nicht, ob das dazu führt, dass es stabiler wird, ehrlich gesagt
führt es eher dazu, dass leute anfangen sowas wie arrows zu ignorieren, weil es zu nervig
ist, weil da so zawsze diese
ja ich ich will mit rein klicken wie sendet man denn jetzt den request ok da muss ich da
muss ich muss ich googeln go lang htp new requests new requests kleint du request ah guck
du mal da ost das ist das ist ja das war mega umständlich ok wir brauchen erst mal einen
kleint ein kleint htp kleint objekt oder struct oder ding wie auch immer man das nennen mag und
dann müssen wir sagen kleint du ich habe es abgesagt ja ich kann nicht so gut über drei
sachen gleichzeitig nachdenken error haben wir kein bloated ok so macht man jetzt das ist ich
muss ehrlich sagen für dass das die go leute so standard library fans sind ich kann es nicht ganz
nachvollziehen die standard library sieht mir sehr lücken behaftet irgendwie aus so weil ich
mein viel umständlicher kannst ja den request kaum noch senden wenn man schön wenn man was
schönes sehen will wie man request sendet ane ich kann ja ich kann ja ich kann ja rider nicht
öffnen weil wenn ich weiter öffne dann sagt er mir mein meine subscription ist abgelaufen ja
muss ich mir echt doch noch mal einloggen im pyson stream sind für eine stunde fertig ja ich
glaube schon nee htp get funktioniert nicht weil ich muss ja so ein query filter ich muss ich muss
ja die die query option setzen das kann man ja bei htp get direkt direkt nicht so so jetzt
schauen wir mal jetzt schauen wir mal ob ich was gelernt habe chat also wir haben als return wert
eher ein silence array jetzt schauen wir mal ob ich moment es muss bei go ja vorne hin ich
habe mal eine dumme frage an euch warum ist in dem fall der parameter hinten und der name vorne und
in dem fall ist der parameter also der typ nicht schwachsinn da gibt keinen sinn was ich sagen
wollte da sind zwar unterschiedliche sachen aber warum ist es ein array slice und kein slice array
oder warum ist es ein warum ist einfach warum ist es so falsch und also warum muss es vorne
sein das finde ich total unintuitiv ist es ist aber glaube ich in in rust auch so und ich glaube
dass der typ hinten kommt ist auch so ein ding man möchte anders sein als c einfach nur warte mal
ab bis du mit erase slices arbeiten musst ja ja guck mal mal also jetzt mache ich erst mal den
request response client to request alles klar so jetzt gucken wir mal ob ich was gelernt habe
vom letzten letzten mal war silences silence silence und jetzt jason decoder das hat mir
letztens der chat beigebracht leute messer feierkuh cute cute ist chat alive so und das ging jetzt
folgendermaßen new jason decoder response body die code in silences so
weil das ist ja ein array was wir da zurück kriegen aber das array ist falsch rumgeschrieben
so das hat mir letztes der chat beigebracht jetzt gucken wir mal ob das funkt was alle
für schmerzen anhändelt error wir händeln den error nicht das kann er sich abgewöhnen ich
händel prinzipiell keine errors so und jetzt haben wir den jason graben gepasst hoffe ich ohne dass
es crashed werden wir gleich sehen und jetzt könnte man theoretisch sagen return silences
so und wenn das jetzt funktioniert dann rindeln dann sollte da jetzt alle gesetzten silences
rauskommen man sieht es funktioniert schon sehr gut es kommt nichts raus
und silences gibt es ja
guck hier hostname poggers moment setze ich ja ja
ach moment moment es ist nicht poggers ist hostname gleich poggers ich muss das auch schon
richtig machen bäm da sind wir ach so ne das kann ich ja nicht ok funst also wir kriegen wir kriegen
die silences zurück so was jetzt noch mega nice wäre was jetzt noch mega nice wäre wobei ich da
wirklich keine ahnung wie man das fintaktisch machen sollten wenn wir so was wie ein result
filter machen könnten also function function result filter dass wir das quasi mit irgendeiner
lambda expression filtern können was da zurück kommt bevor wir es denn zurück bekommen ok mal
gucken go lang beides patrick beides haben wir schon durch funk parameter function parameter
function arguments nee can functions be passed as parameters genau das will ich wissen in dem
fall brauche ich keine generics weil die der typ ist ja klar und wie ist das beispiel fn convert
einfach so type so easy copy paste he lacks critical information ich habe keine ahnung
warum es geht aber es scheint zu funktionieren ok result filter so der parameter ist immer
silence und der return wird ist ein bool weil ich will ja quasi sagen können ich zeige euch das
gleich was ich vor habe ja dann sieht man das ich hoffe es funktioniert also ich will ich will
nämlich so was sagen können guckt mal kann kann auch gar die idee kann autocomplete hoge also ich
will so was machen können guckt mal get silences für das query filter ich nach hosten in poggers
und jetzt will ich sagen können die results will ich filter nach return silence status nicht
expired also ich will nur silences haben die nicht expired sind das ist doch ganz nice so finde ich
jetzt ist nur die frage funktioniert das und wie mache ich das eigentliche filtern hier drinnen
wie mache ich denn das eigentliche filtern hier drinnen jetzt muss ich das von hand machen mit
der schleife muss ich da so was machen das wäre schon ziemlich so biga aber wahrscheinlich ist
das so dass ich brauche auch noch eine result variable oder sowas result irgendwie so ok if
war das ist das ist wirklich mega mega umständlich also if result filter silence
nichts hier ungleich null dann result add nee busch ach moment moment aber das ist die array
syntax leute das ist die array syntax die ist die ist 5 hat in go die ist so ne silences
die ist die ist so also das ist schon echt ziemlich umständlich ok result schauen wir mal ob das
funktioniert gucken wir mal ob das funktioniert was ich mir da gedacht habe also run ja das
funktioniert leute guck mal ich kriege jetzt nur die silences zurück die noch nicht expired sind
so wenn ich jetzt sagen silences gleich expired dann ist das alles das funktioniert es ist nicht
schön aber es funktioniert das ist doch tatsächlich jetzt relativ angenehm zu benutzen oder du sagst
abi ich will alle silences haben beim abrufen filter nach hostname und das ergebnis filter mal
hier nach das ist gar nicht schlecht das kann man tatsächlich benutzen so wir müssen aber noch
mehr gucken also die silen soll nicht nur nicht expired sein sondern die silen soll auch ein
kommentar haben und zwar ein kommentar mit contains includes ne chat nicht nicht back
sie nicht kriegt das alles selbst raus habe ich glück und meine idee ist 5 hat und weiß das ok
google weiß aber string contains string contains function moment was strings strings contain ok
das war den standard library erstellern wohl zu viel arbeit string das string dem string
struct ein paar sinnvolle metoden zu spendieren das ist ja fast so was geiles wie ein c++ standard
to upper und sowas also strings contains so dann dann den text das kommen vergleichen mit
set downtime wenn es da drin enthalten ist und und alles klar jetzt sollte ich nix finden string
ist kein struct nicht was ist denn dann ach irgendein build in oder sowas na wenn es ein
build in ist oder ist es ein value so ne irgendein magic build in typ der das nicht kann soll
leute kurz was zu trinken hol gleich wieder am start ok
wieder da so aber das passt ja das ist doch eigentlich ja also es hat funktioniert was
ich vor habe das kann man doch jetzt wirklich gut lesen ich finde ich finde das ich weiß
jetzt nicht ob das wie sagen sie so schön immer idiomatic idiomatic was auch immer go
ist aber das ist mir egal für mich ist zwei sachen wichtig erstens es muss funktionieren
zweitens es muss am besten auch noch irgendwie ganz gut lesbar sein und wenn diese zwei sachen
erfüllt sind ist mir der rest ziemlich egal so ich muss den kram zweifels weil im halben
jahr wieder verstehen also so jetzt haben wir das jetzt kommen wir jetzt mal weitermachen
was brauchen wir dann sonst noch also wir müssen silences getten und wir müssen silences
createn string ist kein struct daher keine metoden also das habe ich ja schon gelesen
gerade also silences deleten müssen wir auf jeden fall auch silences aber ich würde sagen
das machen wir dann wenn wir so weit sind weil es ist jetzt blöd wenn ich hier weitermache
und alle metoden implementieren dann feststellen ich brauche die eigentlich gar nicht deswegen
machen wir jetzt mal mit unserem kommando zeilen tool weiter hat jemand von euch schon
mal das hier verwendet chat äh ähm vergessen wie es heißt das da urfuff cli der urfuff
hat 18,7000 trillionen sterne und und das ist anscheinend ein go cli framework wo man
so sachen wie argument parsing und sowas mit machen kann es gibt wohl auch noch codra
es gibt wohl auch noch das da aber ich habe mir die hilfeseiten von beiden sachen mal
angeguckt und ich finde ich finde dass das hier irgendwie verständlicher aussieht du
magst bubble t mehr ist bubble t ein command line parser oder go lang wie passt man damit
das ist doch nee das ist das ist ein ui framework für also ich will kommt mal weil das sieht
tatsächlich relativ relativ simpel aus hier das ganze man sagt ihm sagt ihm name vom program
usage was er standardmäßig aufräumen soll aufrufen soll und dann kann man noch ein paar
flex angeben und das war es im endeffekt guck mal das sieht relativ das sieht relativ
easy aus also man kann kann quasi sowas hier machen wenn man jetzt noch den include urfuff
sink ja gut so also sprich ich finde sogar mit den ganzen referenzen und hier so da kann
man sich darüber streiten aber ich finde das sieht relativ gut gut durchblickbar aus
was man da hat so einfach es kann man packages ja aber man wobei ich das immer noch nicht
schön hinkauf hinter mit diesen komischen magic magic urls für packages und package
manager wäre schon was nices so jetzt brauche ich nämlich optionen für mein program nennt
es nicht cccc kontext das heißt kontext bei mir fertig aus kommentieren also wir brauchen
nämlich ein paar optionen wir brauchen nämlich ein paar optionen ne ne das verstehe ich nicht
und am package manager und am package manager würde ich verstehen irgendwas mit eigener
package registry sowas wie nougat oder npm oder so weil das hat auch seine probleme also
url magic url import sachen finde ich blöd das ist das ist dann nur ein schritt besser
als 10 plus plus header files temple ist in hundert sekunden schon gesehen ne ja hat
es und es ist im prinzip genau das gleiche wie nc dass ich das ist referenz adresse wobei
nc plus plus ja was anderes das ist die adresse quasi und das hier ist pointer dereferenzieren
in den eigentlichen typ aber ich glaube du kannst in go du kannst den go 2 null pointer
exception fabrizieren aber ich glaube du kannst nicht so einfach irgendwelche stack overflow
aus und sachen produzieren mit pointer usage
stimmt schon header files ist wirklich das allerschleppste
so also was brauchen wir denn was brauchen wir denn für damit wir ein bisschen progress
machen schreibe ich das jetzt mal wirklich ich sage jetzt nicht ich mache jetzt ein flag
und probiere es aus wir schreiben jetzt wirklich mal die ganzen flags hin die wir brauchen
also das erste ist wir brauchen ein string flag das heißt aber nicht language sondern
das heißt comment wenn ich das einfach und usage
und ich glaube ich habe mir nämlich vorhin die hilfeseite schon angeschaut ich glaube
allias ist es da kann man dann kurzschreibweise von angeben
es wäre dann quasi minus z im moment minus z haben wir schon für clear deswegen habe
ich das reason genannt oder ich könnte auch einfach message nennen so kurzschreibweise
ist dann minus er so wenn wir jetzt help eingeben dann sollte schon mal was halbwegs sinnvolles
bei rumkommen mal her an den punkt keckel was jetzt flag minus er beginnt mit minus
es haben flex so ansicht dass sie mit minus beginnen ja es kann auch sein dass es anders
funktioniert das funktioniert genauso ach man muss das minus ohne das minus der macht
magic ach hier guckt mal der macht der macht magic ist das ist value der default ja das
default soll nee moment default soll silence sein fertig default value ok so dann brauchen
wir als nächstes ein weiteres command line flag das muss ein user sein das ist easy das
ist genau das gleiche user u die fault value haben wir gerade nicht usage user oder created
by user so dann brauchen wir eine startzeit und das ist auch der grund warum ich warum
ich vorhin bei der google suche diese cli parsing und und application framework gefunden
haben weil wir brauchen eine startzeit und minus s und dort kann man folgendes machen
man kann direkt den graben hier drinnen passen lassen das ist das was wir mit rust überhaupt
nicht hingekriegt haben wo rust wollte dass ich in eigenen duration parser und so programmier
ja also man kann quasi sagen dann was ist das hier usage text start time of silence
default current time oder so so und was man jetzt machen kann ist man kann es hier angeben
layout und dann kann man einstellen wie er diesen ganzen krempel parsen soll und jetzt
kommt wieder diese diese moment nicht time layout oder mal ach man das ist ja noch stringflag
es soll ja time es soll ja time stamp glaube sein time stamp ja sowas wie gesagt die hilfe
seite habe ich vorhin schon gesehen timestamp black so und da kann man dann sagen wie er
die zeit passen soll die man eben übergibt also sprich
das ist auch so ein ding was mich an go ein bisschen nervt mein gott wie sind wie sind
richtige die richtigen date time strings für für go probieren wir das jetzt aus hier
ein pass ja keck hier layout also was ich haben will ist folgendes meine die zeiteingabe
ist minute doppelpunkt sekunde also 04 05 obvius obvius nicht minute sekunde was laber
ich denn für blödsinn nicht minute sekunde stunde minute 15 04 immer gleich ab das kann
sich doch keiner merken also sprich time value time layout so value die default value ist
time now wenn das funktioniert nein funktioniert nicht ja wie setzt man den default value das
muss ich mir gleich nochmal angucken wie man den default value setzt genauso wie für für
den user den default value wobei wie setzen wir den default value was will er denn haben
für ein value der will das will er haben time stamp flag ich könnte das weil das coole
ist den default value den zeigt er mir hier in der hilfe an das heißt aktuell steht hier
nur start of silence und kein default wert wenn ich irgendwie einen default wert anlegen
könnte wäre schon äußerst nice ja das funktioniert nicht und er zeigt uns auch nicht als beispiel
ne time zone aber time zone können wir angeben time zone ist location gibt es in go irgendwie
so convention dass man globale variablen oder so irgendwie static sachen groß schreibt
also brauche ich quasi sowas wie irgendwie time stamp so was da time cli time stamp ok
now time stamp jetzt muss ich mir noch die zeit setzen now time stamp set location ja
auf jeden fall auch schon mal nicht verkehrt location in go bedeutet groß dass es public
ist ok so und wie setzt man da jetzt die zeit set value set time stamp value time time
point now so und nun können wir wenn wir glück haben sagen value now time warum geht das
jetzt schon wieder nicht cannot use cli time stamp s type time stamp muss dann unter vormachen
ah yes obvious guckt und jetzt haben wir hier ein default dran stehen ein äußerst hässliches
default jetzt haben wir immer die aktuelle zeit als default dran stehen die das kann man
das irgendwie besser die fall text klingt gut now ts string sieht immer noch kacke aus
format nee value format stunde minute stunde minute reicht guck mal jetzt haben wir hier
eine ordentliche ausgabe von default also sprich als default sagt doch einfach current time
nee ich will es ja formatieren sonst sieht es doch kacke aus und ich will auch dass das
hier und das hier das gleiche benutzt weil sonst leckt kurz und hier steht eine andere
zeit als es eigentlich benutzt intern das ist doch eigentlich ganz sinnvoll massive
richtig massive so jetzt haben wir aktuell jetzt haben wir eine ordentliche ausgabe so
was kommt als nächstes duration duration kommt als nächstes glaube ich duration parsing
das war das was mich in rust wirklich zur weisglut gebracht hat ok also copy pasten wir den krempel
mal duration das gibt es hier als als argument das gibt es hier als argument das ist der
grund warum ich dieses framework überhaupt gefunden habe vorhin da muss man nicht so
viel selbst machen ok alias nee also das ding heißt duration der alias für dieses format
ist minus d layout time zone brauche ich net usage is duration of silence so default text
die fall text brauche man net die fall value ist time minute mal 15 15 minuten ist die fall
setting wenn man nichts angibt so und was brauche ich jetzt noch eigentlich nur ich
kann es leider in mein dotnet programm nicht reingucken das ist ziemlich ziemlich pain
champ dass es nicht funktioniert jetzt muss ich tatsächlich mein dotnet programm in wim
aufmachen ich fasse es nicht wobei ich kann ich mache den studio code auf da kann man
das wenigstens halbwegs lesen yes yes wir trusten kann man kann man sich wenigstens
kann man sich wenigstens angucken genau was braucht man eigentlich was hat er denn für
schmerzen not all code path return hat das programm funktioniert das ist überhaupt nichts
ok keine ahnung was der für schmerz hat das ist lauffähig das funktioniert aber was brauchen
wir für kommando zeilen argument list clear duration start reason ja user haben wir jetzt
noch dazu also list und clear brauchen wir noch wir machen auch noch einen debug flag
oder sowas also ein bool flag was sich nennt list minus l so was da kein punkt am ende
brauchen wir nicht overrated plaudit plaudit punkte am ende so also list clear und zum
schluss machen wir noch mal ohne alias sowas wie minus minus debug clear ah debug kriegt
auch kein usage das ist für die interne und und um ein arbeitskollege zu erfreuen brauchen
wir noch ein extra bool flag das ist ein spezielles bool flag für den zwenn der kriegt eine
eigene option bei dem programm weil weil er will immer irgendwelche spezielle also das
wenn es jemand wenn du was wenn du wenn du was vorstellst und zeigt der sagt immer wenn
du was sagst ja könnte man da nicht machen dass es noch irgendwie dort die tabelle links
zentriert und kann es an der stelle nicht umgedreht formatiert werden oder kann es
nicht so sein dass es exit code 0 oder exit code 1 macht und ich weiß schon und ich weiß
schon dass da irgendwas in der richtung kommt deswegen kriegt er sein eigenes flag und dann
sage ich zu ihm wenn er was erzählt sage ich wenn ruft das mal auf mach minus minus dran
als parameter es macht nix das macht nichts kann man hinten sagen hinten heckl aller
hinten zu man sieht so nicht mal in der hilfe perfekt es kriegt auch sein eigenes ganz
eigenes command line argument und es funktioniert auch guckt er schmeißt kein fehler nee eigentlich
also wahrscheinlich weil ich noch keine action habe oder so ist der eck ja so ok action das
ist das was er auf ruft am anfang ok kurz überlegen machen wir das alles in line nee
machen wir nicht wir machen eine function die heißt da nicht mehr die heißt keiner run oder
so und das machen wir ein bisschen wie die wie die dort net von gibt es ein ordentliches
dependency injection in go wahrscheinlich nicht oder ich meine ich gebe zu das wäre
krasse overkill für eine kommando zeilen anwendung die nichts macht außer ein paar web requests
schicken aber einfach nur mal so interesse halber das ist go land ja so und die diese
funktion kriegt jetzt die richtigen parameter schon rausgepasst und und über übergeben
ja also sowas wie start start time so duration time duration mehr fällt mir gerade nicht
ein so action run wir behandeln keine fehler wie oft soll ich das dem ja noch sagen absolut
absoluter blut error handling z-buffer moin so also wie funktioniert das hier jetzt action
grufe ich da drin jetzt einfach mein kram auf wahrscheinlich also wie bekomme ich denn
mir action wie bekomme ich denn hier meine parameter jetzt raus args
also context string und dann wie die dinge heißen
marsch in gaming danke für den zapp also sprich sowas dann hier context
timestamp und wie habe ich das genannt start also start time gleich dann übergebe ich das
an ran dann haben wir noch duration wobei duration kann ich doch so direkt eigentlich kann ich das
alles so direkt duration aber mal hier so was hat er was hat er für schmerzen was mag er nicht
missing return statement wir machen kein error handling error handling is overrated outdated
start time erst ah das ist ein pointer das muss die die referenz werden also okay wir
könnten theoretisch list und clear hier drinne schon abfangen dann muss es nicht in der main
funktion laufen also if überlegen if list dann ja return ich habe noch keine funktion in der
die das kann rinnt die gibt's die gibt's doch nicht aber die gibt's bald so und dann ist clear dann
rufen wir auf clear clear silences und ansonsten machen wir einfach auch ein error zurück und
gut ist ansonsten rufen wir das so auf und das müsste doch eigentlich schon soweit funktionieren
so error zurückgeben so langsam aber sicher blicke ich zumindest bei den basics halbwegs
durch so dann brauchen wir noch eine function rinnt silences brauchen wir und einer die list
moment kann go land sowas sekunde kann mal ausprobieren kann go so kann go return heckl
kann go für mich so was generieren go land ne doch great function nice poc progge das heißt
wir testen mal wie das funktioniert wir machen das hier mal weg und lassen uns das lasst uns das auto
jetzt noch mal voll nice return null wir machen kein error handling cool das gefällt mir dass
das auto generieren kann das finde ich sehr sehr nice ok machen wir das run auch unten drunter aber
das run auch unten drunter hat jemand erfahrung mit dem compiler von in video und sie mit nein
habe ich nicht ich vermute mal er möchte irgendwelche kuda geschichten oder so machen
ich würde jetzt mal raten so ok jetzt jetzt muss ich mal in mich gehen weil jetzt haben wir so die
die boilerplate geschichte fertig jetzt muss ja die funktion eingebaut werden das ding hatte
ja absolut noch keine funktion außer dass es schöne es kann schöne leute einfach sagen es kann
schöne hilfemenüs zeigen das ist ja auch schon mal nice aber hilfemenü allein wird glaube ich
noch kein großartig schocken ok es heißt noch ein new cli application das will ich nicht dass
es so heißt das soll heißen usage name set down time soll das heißen new cli ok nicht
usage description oder sowas description kackel ein bisschen twitchy mods reinbringen description
jawoll so ist das so ist das gut beste beste description ich meine wir könnten seriös sein
was ist eigentlich der unterschied zwischen usage in dem fall in der ah
ist usage und description das gleiche in dem fall description passt besser
user und description ist genau das ach nee ist es nicht ok dann dann lassen wir es so ist auch ok
die fall 19 07 und 15 näher wie soll ich was soll ich sonst anders reinschreiben es ist ich meine
ich könnte reinschreiben die fall current time oder so ja du hast recht minus er ist egal das
verwendet eh keiner die sagen alle basic standardmäßig wir könnten minus m für message machen minus c ist
schon für clear wir könnten wir könnten message message machen m konnten wir vielleicht besser
anstatt friesen ja message message eine idee ist schon duration so und jetzt und jetzt überlegen
also ral clear also wenn ich minus l mache passiert aktuell nichts genau minus c passiert auch nichts
und alles andere geht dann in in die in der in die eigentliche main funktion würde ich sagen ok
5 hat time jetzt müssen wir die eigentliche funktion da mal langsam aber sicher implementieren
dass es überhaupt was sinnvolles macht ich mache vorher noch eine sache und zwar die back weil ich
mir schon vorstellen kann es wird mal irgendwann nicht funktionieren will ich so ein paar basic
sachen ausgeben zum beispiel was ich als alert manager url und sowas verwende also fm brindlen
was geben wir dann mal aus später aber die back location location ap endpoint fqdn ja reicht
eigentlich weil ich könnte mir vorstellen wenn das nicht funktioniert ist es tatsächlich nicht
schlecht ein paar infos zu haben was er benutzt und woran es hängt ok also jetzt wird es etwas
komplizierter jetzt muss ich das einbauen ich habe hier unten schon ein bisschen was gemacht
alert manager api ja was wir machen das machen wir einfach mal global ich habe keinen bock das
überall durch zu durch zu passen wir fällt nichts besseres ein außer den kram global zu machen also
ansonsten müsste ich das ja wie jeder funktion irgendwie mitgeben alert manager api
also den kram kann schon mal das muss ich aufheben das brauche ich gleich noch machen wir mal machen
wir mal das list ich glaube das list ist tatsächlich noch relativ easy minus l also sprich was macht
der beim auflisten der der silences dann dann dann fangen wir dann fangen wir doch damit erstmal an also print print silences ist nichts
implementiert ok also wir rufen erstmal alle aktiven silences ab aus dem monitoring so alert
manager api heißt das ding so wir filtern nach alles was nicht expired ist und was set down time
im comment drin stehen hat da muss ich jetzt sicherstellen dass wir einen testeintrag haben
dass das funktioniert edit set down time weil irgendwie muss ich das markieren dass es von
meinem programm angelegt ist so jetzt habe ich alles silences an der stelle jetzt muss ich den kram
sortieren nach end datum wir benennen noch mal ein bisschen was um das soll nicht startet add
heißen sondern soll startet add utc ans add utc heißt weil der alert manager hat alle zeiten in utc
und meine zeit ist in cst und das ist sonst total verwirrend und ich blicke nicht durch ob die
zeiten stimmen wie sortiere ich denn jetzt ein array silences go sort array sortieren ist eklig ich
gehe davon aus es ist so fast alles was ich sehe in der standard library nicht gerade schön ok sort
strings das wird nicht funktionieren ich habe da objekte drin einfach nur sort werde ich nicht
sagen können sort ins der schon blöd wenn man keine generics hat oder ok mittlerweile haben
sie das ja aber ok sort es gibt wohl ein sort sort sort sort slice slice table ach nee stable
ok der unterschied zwischen sort slice und sort slice stable ist wahrscheinlich das eine ist
quick sort und das andere ist was bubble sort ich ich würde sagen wir machen slice
sort slice ok silence sortieren und jetzt gibt man dort eine function was nennt int
den int ach ist das der index oder was ok das check ich nicht sort slice go lang example
das ist ein index das ist der index im array ja dumm wenn man keine generics hat hatte hatte
aber anscheinend er noch nicht eingebaut hat ja das ist wahrscheinlich der index gut dass du uns
das mitteilst hätten wir das nicht gewusst wäre dramatisch gewesen dramatische folgen aber lasst
ihr schmecken pepo fett style also das ok das denn nicht a und b oder so keine an oder index
eigentlich sollte man das i1 i2 nennen dass man das irgendwie versteht was da passiert also was
soll man machen jetzt monka es man das ist das ist wirklich eklig ist wirklich eklig
also so moment ich sortiere nach was startet oder endzeit leute den da nach dort nee nach
nach was sortiere ich am besten startzeit oder endzeit startzeit oder ich glaube endzeit ist zu
weird weird champ oder end na doch nee eigentlich ist die zeit wann es aufhört für mich interessanter
also end utc funktioniert natürlich nicht wäre auch zu einfach gewesen wenn es einfach funktioniert
ach so daytime geht ja nicht i2 ist i1 plus 1 korrekt das ist der erste index naja nicht
unbedingt nicht unbedingt das ist implementations frage also meistens ist es wahrscheinlich index
1 und 2 oder plus 1 aber muss es nicht sein sind einfach die zweite indexe der zwei elemente die
man vergleichen soll also da bin ich echt ein bisschen dort nett verwöhnt weil da könnte ich
einfach so was hier machen oder bei silence ends at was ist silence ist für ein typ hier ein strukt
von mir also sage ich da jetzt nicht kleiner gleich sondern einfach bevor weil es ist ja ein
date time also bevor so na ob das funktioniert
es wäre jetzt eine gute gelegenheit sich go generics anzugucken aber will ich nicht weil
ich will ich will weiter weitermachen ok soll ich ich lege noch mal testweise ein paar moment
wo haben wir denn unsere unser dotnet programm liegen hier post jam dotnet ich muss mal ein paar
maintenen zu setzen leute damit ich damit ich da welche drin stehen hab so alert manager gucken ja ok
auf den auf den haus nahmen will ich filtern genau hier local haus gibt mir ausnehmen local haus
local haus punkt local domain sehr außerirdisch so sort und jetzt schauen wir mal ob das ob das
sortiert ist jetzt schauen wir mal ob das sinnvoll sortiert ist minus l fängt an 17 59 hört auf 18
nur 14 17 das sieht sortiert aus easy ja aber nicht schön nicht schön easy aber echt nicht
schön so jetzt brauchen wir noch eine ordentliche tabellen ausgabe dafür habe ich das hier gefunden
leute auf github da kann man table da kann man tables tables machen im terminal mit und
uns komische dinger im terminal meinen und es muss ja ein bisschen fancy aussehen deswegen
gucken wir uns mal das example hier vorn an libby malen genau so ach nee moment ich muss
es noch importieren skolle skolle skolle hallo sync ja excel genau naja vielleicht nicht ganz
so fancy wie excel es mag er nicht leute das mag er nicht doch es funktioniert leute kommt
mal da tabelle aber die programme von meinem dort net program sind deutlich schöner guckt
mal minus minus minus minus ran guck mal hier die sehen deutlich web 3.0 liga aus als die da
das ist viel schöner als das da aber ich will mal nicht so anspruchsvoll sein passt schon hauptsache
hauptsache tabelle also start and time left created by brauche da start and time left created
bei oder so message nennen wir das message message ok passt so den inhalt der ergibt
natürlich überhaupt keinen sinn wie kann ich da jetzt was hintendran hängen ok table table
oder sowas nee das wäre ja auch oh nee muss ich jetzt wird diese ekliche append syntax
machen append oder so nee pointer what nein nein das ist moment das ist ein table printer
das ist wieder was anderes aber wahrscheinlich muss ich das da erst mal rausnehmen und das
so reinschreiben und jetzt kann ich sagen table append ok table append da muss ich jetzt
den gleichen krempel ja noch mal hintendran hängen funktioniert das denn nein natürlich
nicht was ist es denn für ein typ ok das ist nicht hilfreich was ist es denn für ein typ
was ist chat was ist das hier für ein typ ich bekomme halt hier keine hilfe in der anzeige
ein string array nee kein string array ein array aus string arrays also ein nested array
also ist das hier quasi ein string array oder nee aber moment wir sind ja in go wie das
funktioniert jetzt wait a minute das geht warum muss ich denn den typ explizit da vorschreiben
sollte er nicht wissen was das für ein typ ist weil ich meine meine data table hat halt
string elemente string array elemente naja gut muss ich muss ich nicht verstehen soll
mir recht sein also da müssen wir jetzt ja die ganzen sachen hier anhängen also war mal
eine schleife die haben wir nicht an dem moment über alle silences so und da drin machen wir
jetzt table append machen wir das auch mal unten hin und das auch mal unten hin so also
als erstes brauchen wir die startzeit also quasi silence utc start und dann wahrscheinlich
string weil geht sonst nicht ok end time es ist keine valid array sind tags nur geschweifte
klammern anzugeben ja aber warum geht es dann hier und hier nicht warum darf ich das da
machen und da nicht so startzeit endzeit time left time left muss ich ausrechnen dass das
funktioniert also wie machen man das jetzt time left vielleicht so stringer
da verstehe ich den zusammenhang nicht ein stringer das ist so was wie to string über
schreiben das brauche ich glaube ich nicht so also time left ist quasi silence moment
das muss ich in der schleife machen so silence ends at utc abziehen davon time now ergibt
das sinn also die zeit bis die silence abläuft ist die endzeit minus die aktuelle zeit die
aktuelle zeit bis ja das ergibt sin das tatsächlich das ergibt sind so round auf seconds ok ok
time left hätten wir auch string so created by ist wieder einfach sila silence created
by silence created by comment ok er gibt nichts aus warum nicht weil ich nicht render moment
ich render ja gar nicht hier und dann irgendwie render render ja und error ignorieren ich
ich mache kein fehler war schickt hier einfach immer alle alle er war so tabel ok hey funktioniert
leute guck mal und guck mal das sortieren funktioniert auch es fängt an mit 2 mit 52
time left 580 das sortieren funktioniert auch aber das ist halt mega hässlich formatiert
wie sieht das mit der upcoming silence aus also start time um 23 uhr starte in zwei stunden
ja ok dann sagt er drei stunden ok das muss ich noch abfangen wenn die noch gar nicht
gestartet hat also time left in seconds wunderbar dann machen wir sowas wie heim lefz heim lefz
message oder so heim lefz string beste da weißt du gleich bescheid so weil wir können
das nämlich so machen wenn wenn die silence noch nicht gestartet ist dann zeigen wir an
was in state steht und in state sollte dann sowas wie pending oder upcoming oder sowas
drin stehen so das heißt wir müssen jetzt gucken ist der silence status ich könnte mir
vorstellen das kann man auch noch eine ganze ecke eleganter machen ist der silence status
active dann sagen wir heim lefz dann print dann geben wir die echte zeit aus in zahlen
und ansonsten geben wir aus dass es upcoming ist oder sowas pending genau ich finde das
format gar nicht schlecht ehrlich gesagt ja aber nicht so advanced wie c so das ist gar
nicht schlecht das ist genau das was ich haben will als ausgabe nur mit dem duration wäre
noch toll in der tabelle noch eine duration ich meine wir haben start end und time left
ob das reicht oder was meint ihr noch duration mein können wir machen ist jetzt nicht so
als wäre das in irgendeiner art und weise duration als wäre das irgendwie schlimm
vor created by so duration ist relativ relativ easy die duration ist silence end minus silence
starts ane moment sab sab muss man machen nicht als wo string sein ok ja ne das muss
man das muss wir hier oben machen das muss man das muss man rounden das sieht kacke aus
das sieht das sieht dumm aus duration das sieht dumm aus rounds auf die sekunde und
jetzt duration ring ja ja ja chat gute idee passt doch 15 minuten und davon time left
zwei minuten endzeit ist dann dann und dann wunderbar finde ich gut schön jetzt muss
wir die zeit noch ordentlich formatieren weil die sieht ziemlich ziemlich beknackt aus
wir müssen utc vor allem noch umrechnen leute das ist ja utc wir wollen das ja gar nicht
utc haben wir wollen local time haben location in in location 23 das ist schon besser in
location ok ja das ist ok so als sozusagen format das ding muss noch ordentlich formatiert
werden und zwar wollen wir jetzt haben moment tag monat ja stunde minute ach sekunde können
wir uns glaube ich sparen ok in diesem format ja das sieht doch jetzt wirklich schon ganz
brauchbar aus guckt mal startzeit von dann bis dann time left ne zeitzone brauchen wir
nicht die anzeige ist immer in lokaler zeit ich will überhaupt nicht dass die leute wissen
dass das ding auf utc läuft es ist immer die lokale zeit und die lokale zeit ist bei mir
hardcoded auf europe berlin
wir sind unten so tatsächlich das ist doch echt ganz nice ja ich also ich denke das können
wir so lassen guckt mal unsere unsere silenzen sind ausgelaufen die waren bloß auf 35 sekunden
und es hat funktioniert seht ihr ich war wir können jetzt wir können jetzt noch ein paar
anlegen aber mal duration mal welche mit keine ahnung zwei stunden oder so legen wir noch
mal ein paar an unit tests also wenn ihr seht wie oft ich fehler händler dann sollte klar
sein ob es noch unit test gibt oder nicht einfach fehlerfrei programmieren easy so das
finde ich tatsächlich ganz nett das gefällt mir jetzt so wie es ist ok also das haben
wir print silences wunderbar next clear silences ist das nächste also sprich alle silences
löschen die lasst mal überlegen fehlt noch irgendwas bei print nee eigentlich nicht
ist alles alles sinnig oder ich meine du kannst ja auch angeben lassen wann was startet und
dann ist gut ok als nächstes machen wir clear ich glaube clear ist ein bisschen
feifertiger id nee die id ist egal es macht nur macht es nur unübersichtlicher ok also
das brauchen wir hier oben auch auf jeden fall exakt das exakt das gleiche würde ich
sagen ok clear doch ich habe eine idee was wir noch einbauen können wir können wir
können noch gucken if silences ich will länge gucken wie guckt man denn länge in go cap
was ist der unterschied ah das ist wie viel theoretisch reinpassen würde bevor er resize
muss und länge ist wie viel elemente drin sind rate ich jetzt einfach mal weiß nicht
ob das stimmt so wenn länge gleich gleich null dann sagen wir sowas wie no matching
sei ist silences found und dann muss das raketen nee was moment was ist ein gutes emoji dafür
set set face der da oder der da die rakete rakete haben wir schon setke was ein aski setke
ok weil ihr seid setke weil ihr seid chat copy image we get hallo an ich copy image copy
image link we get pog nie war wie ist das andere j
color fill hier setke
aber das kann kriege ich da so nicht rein 100 sekunden 100 sekunden templo ist nicht
Leute wie kriege ich das kriege ich da gar nicht gescheit rein
ich kann da nicht einfach sehr gerein kopieren das in pisen würde das funktionieren da würde
ich dann einfach so machen und dann wird der string nicht es käme hat go so was wie go
längs string string literal mit mit stimmt ich könnte in online escape tool verwenden
wenn ich hier sagen prindle moment rider hat das formatiert für mich sekunde mal
kurz schauen moment minus mensch go fack mich nicht ab
es funktioniert selke es macht auf jeden fall meine farbausgabe kaputt da unten drunter
das lasse ich drin das lasse ich drin aber nicht so dass das muss ich mir gucken wie
ich das anders formatiere aber aber aber es funktioniert im prinzip schon das film moment
irgendwie span terminal gerade kap kaputt champ normalerweise war das doch mal blau
keine ahnung wir haben es irgendwie gebraked gerade
so also next clear silences weiter im weiter im text also wir wollen alle silences löschen die
es gibt das heißt wir müssen so was hier machen von der idee her wir rufen alle silences ab die
vom programm erstellt wurden und die nicht expired sind weil die liten bedeutet expire
setzen nicht wirklich die liten also da machen wir das gleiche hier nochmal no matching silences
found return ich aus irgendwelchen gründen habe ich mir ganz gute er aus zu return die ich eh nicht benutze so
no matching silences found so clear silences also vor wir brauchen im prinzip wieder die
gleiche schleife wie hier unten nur nur mit weniger inhalt und und also wir brauchen die
ganzen schmorder hier brauchen wir nicht mehr so und jetzt müssen wir es löschen also rein von
der idee her ist es alert manager api delete silences silences id so nur mit dem unterschied
dass es diese diese funktionen noch nicht gibt create method delete also muss sagen go land ist
tatsächlich ziemlich high iq guck mal da kann es sogar für mich anlegen und sogar mit den richtigen
sogar mit der richtigen id obendrinne stimmt die bedingung beim wer wo was welches wer
was meinste state ja alles was nicht expired ist die will ich die will ich löschen ja ich
will alles was aktiv ist löschen so also alert manager delete silences wie macht man ein delete
da wirst du jetzt wieder in die schwäger api gucken ich war ich war mal ein paar tabs zu
kann bis sie zu unübersichtlich die schwäger api delete einfach silences id ok das ist
tatsächlich relativ easy also sprich eigentlich können wir doch eigentlich sagen htp delete ok
es ist go ich hätte ich hätte wissen müssen dass die standard library nix taugt an der stelle
wieder das ist doch bescheuert warum gibt es warum gibt es get und warum gibt es post warum
gibt es nicht mal mindestens noch delete und update ne was was sind die vier dinge die man
braucht standardmäßig öfters delete post get putt putt ne patch nicht putt putt meine ich ja aber
warum ist das da nicht drinnen das ist ziemlich ziemlich beweger ok dann kopieren wir uns das mal
hierher request new request method obwohl es da gibt das ist das ist wirklich das ist wirklich
maximal bescheuert dass man das nicht da integriert hat ok api url plus silences ne plus silence
slash plus id ja ich weiß dass das hier nicht schön ist sowas zu machen aber die standard
library hat keine url join methode und jetzt sagen wir client du requests und natürlich wird
der error ignorieren was sonst mehrere errors ignorieren alles ignorieren wie ignoren alle
errors so delete silence ja das sollte das sollte jetzt so weit funktionieren ok in klein sagen
was haben wir denn all silences for this post have been removed hog set by this program
wir sparen uns einfach text wir schreiben einfach nur progo rein wenn man nur eine
remove möchte hat man pech da muss man ins web interface gehen ja aber 119 ist noch nicht
aus go so schauen wir mal ob das mit dem delete funktioniert ops ich habe mein terminal geschlossen
ne wo müssen wir hin go bosschamp jetzt ist wieder blau guckt also list geht jetzt
klären wir mal alles aus hat nicht funktioniert hat nicht funktioniert leute ich weiß aber
nehmen nicht warum es nicht funktioniert hat das müssen wir jetzt irgendwie die bag dfx
macht er denn hier eine schleife überhaupt lull error handling ist sowas von bloated
aber minus z ja schleife macht er all silences id
ne agil ist es nicht ist zu veröffentlichen was nicht funktioniert warum funktioniert
mein krempel nicht den ich hier gemacht habe warum warum geht es nicht was ist hier was
ist hier kaputt silence delete id ok es steht da steht da eine id drinne aber es funktioniert
nicht ok da müssen wir uns doch die response angucken man die response ist was ist jetzt
ahja doppelpunkt es hat alles funktioniert
ich lösche auf jeden fall schon mal nicht das richtige
1 2 3 4 stück der sollte 5 1 2 3 4 5 sollte er versuchen zu löschen
ja die errors bringen wir aber an der stelle auch nichts was hat er jetzt für schmerzen
ne ne da gibt es kein error ach mensch god ist so nervig an manchen stelle
ey mann dass diese sprache fackt mich teilweise so krass ab was ist das für eine scheiße
wieder ich mein warum darf ich die variablen nicht so drinnen lassen und ich meine ich
weiß dass sie nicht benutzt wenn ich will sie jetzt auch gar nicht benutzen aber nachher
schon also das ist wirklich so babysitting was ich echt nicht gebrauchen kann es gibt
kein fehler ist alles ok das backend ist auch go ich lösche ich das falsche oder was
es gibt keine permissions ok error handling kann wieder weg es gibt kein error error is
bloated prominent so also er löscht alles aber er löscht auch gleichermaßen nix
god go mann so eine nervige dreck sprache was das angeht ok also warum warum löscht
er das nicht das verstehe ich nicht er findet aber er löscht es nicht was macht er denn
überhaupt für einen request lass mal kurz gucken macht er das denn vielleicht verkehrt
delete so a local host api silence wegen den doppelten slashes vielleicht tja
zu dumm dass go keine url punkt join sache in der standard library hat das ist kein layer
acht problem ich wollte es von anfang an richtig machen die go standard library hat einfach
nix mit der man das machen kann gescheit ich wollte es von anfang an richtig machen um
genau sowas zu vermeiden was halt richtig hängen geblieben ist also dann lege ich das
mit ohne slash hinten aber das ist wirklich richtig richtig dämlich gut funktioniert
go 1.19 enjoyer die gibt es noch gar nicht das ist noch nicht released das ist noch gar
nicht raus ja pass join gibts ja aber url punkt join gibts nicht und pass punkt join
funktioniert für urls für urls natürlich nicht so also so die die funktionalität drum
herum haben wir jetzt jetzt bräuchten wir
immer kann man sowas machen kann man sowas machen request url pass gleich pass dort join
oder so da muss ich aber wahrscheinlich sowas hier machen ja immer kurz checken ob das jetzt
funktioniert oder besser gesagt ob das funktionieren würde tragen wir es mal wieder falsch ein
ach so ich muss erstmal das silence wieder anlegen lul naja oh hier das ist das silence
anleger eu warum löscht er jetzt doppelt oder ist mein print einfach doppelt drinne
aber mein print ist doppelt drinne äh jetzt so würde das silence äh warte mal ne moment
das kann ja so nicht funktionieren ähm so und all die ja jetzt funktioniert ok so kann
man dann kann man so auch nichts verkehrt machen das muss ich das muss ich dann hier
oben auch machen aber das ist doch mal also das ist hässlich wie die nacht guckt euch
das mal an ne ne ne ne also so da müsst ihr unbedingt was standard library technisch machen
das kann so nicht bleiben so dann machen wir das so dann passt das ok und jetzt an die
eigentliche hauptfunktionalität weil naja das listen und und löschen und so ist ja
alles schön und gut aber wir wollen ja sachen erstellen wir wollen ja neue silences anlegen
also ok lasst mal überlegen wie wie fangen wir denn da jetzt an wir verwerten mal ein
paar sachen die wir die wir schon gemacht haben die wir die wir schon im letzten stream
gemacht haben von dem was man hier was man hier braucht also ja das in kaddi die haben
wahrscheinlich komplett eigene library für url handling und sowas gebaut glaubt mir
das standard library kriegst du dir erst ab ok start time now now brauchen wir anscheinend
ok start time haben wir schon system user system user könnten wir doch anlegen lassen
aber ich habe eine idee system user könnten wir in main system user könnten wir in main
schon anlegen lassen an der stelle hier allerdings nicht so wie es hier steht sondern dass es
dann als default value drin steht also system user gleich blablabla username username so
dann ist das default value bei user username dann sieht man nämlich auch was er standardmäßig
nehmen würde nämlich default max also die folgtheit der user der wo man das ausführt
ja so username ja passt doch eigentlich da können wir das nämlich hier gleich übergeben
username string oder sollten wir das vielleicht besser irgendwie global setzen global global
machen wir da aber nix global ist pains champ wir machen noch message string user ok
also start time duration message message ist aber ein string argument message und jetzt
brauchen wir noch was brauchen wir jetzt noch wir kriegen kein highlight user username und
aber genau perfekt so und jetzt können wir anfangen date time now wir können auch sie
was wir machen wir machen sonst jetzt einfach eine einfach weil wir haben sie ja oben schon
mal ausgeführt wir geben es einfach als parameter mit so now easy ok da fehlten irgendwie so
dann schrei ich mir einmal now aufrufen ja so und da können wir jetzt reinschreiben was
man soll dann brauchen wir diesen krempel nicht mal das habe ich ja oben schon abgefackelt
hostname ja hostname brauchen wir definitiv hostname brauchen wir hostname brauchen wir
aber doch bei den anderen funktionen auch wenn ich das rechtliche erinnerung habe ja
guckt mal hier hostname hostname gleich ok hostname muss glaubt da geht nichts anderes
drum herum hostname fqdn hostname muss global sein gibt es irgendwie die möglichkeit dns
für localhost zu machen go lang dns localhosts fqdn weil standardmäßig nimmt es bloß den
normalen namen der bei mir progas ist aber ich will den fqdn von dem system haben how
to find best fqdn for localhost best ane the nicht best ich ruf doch keine kommando zeilen
what das mache ich jetzt ganz bestimmt nicht um den fqdn vom lokalen system rauszukriegen
das sind das hier go fqdn hört sich nach der library an die das macht go lang package
providing access to full qualif excellent das will ich haben genau das will ich haben
show max show max park the show max hostname wie heißt das fqdn go fqdn ok leute ich bin
zu ppega das zu zu benutzen habe ich was falsch gemacht examples ah moment ich noob da muss
github davor so geht das nämlich auch und dann einfach fqdn fqdn hostname und wir sehen
wieder exzellentes error handling so wie man es macht hostname fqdn weil dann kann ich
nämlich die ganzen sachen dort wo ich das aktuell hardcoded drin stehen habe wegschmeißen
zu hostname plus so exzellent ja ja über die shell könnte man das ohne probleme raus
kommen ich will keine shell kommandos aufrufen dafür alles klar ok jetzt die eigentliche
funktionalität für dieses tool hostname haben wir panic scheiß drauf start time start
time passen müssen wir auch nicht mehr haben wir schon alles gemacht so dann fangen wir
an message also gucken wir uns mal an was mache ich in meinem dotnet program als erstes
set downtime anhängen an message ok das mache ich hier auch gucken ob das die gleiche syntax
ist hey tatsächlich das ist der marker im web interface woran ich meine selbst gesetzten
silencers und downtimes erkenne mach mal ausrufe zeichen heute da gibt es eine kleine
erklärung also ich habe ein tool in dotnet mit dem du monitoring silencers setzen kannst
von allen unsere server aus und das versuche ich gerade in go nachzubauen einfach weil
es geht einfach weil es geht kein tieferen sinn einfach weil es geht so da kannst du
wenn du auf dem system drauf bist dort wartungsarbeiten machen willst eingeben ja ich mache jetzt
wartungsarbeiten und dann schlägt für dieses system die nächsten 15 minuten lang kein
check mehr an und alarmiert auch keine leute dass das system down ist und sowas ok also
message anhängen dann müssen wir diesen check hier machen genau if start time mach
man kommt nanosekunden machen wir auch noch keckel schadet nichts location also was das
hier macht ist folgendes das guckt ob die zeit die eingegeben wurde in der vergangenheit
liegt und wenn die zeit also stellt euch mal vor ihr loggt euch das ist muss super precise
mit nanosekunden sein stellt euch vor ihr loggt euch um 23.50 auf dem server ein weil
ihr um 015 wartungsarbeiten macht und ihr gebt ein start der wartungsarbeit 015 dann
nimmt er standardmäßig den aktuellen tag und der aktuelle tag ist ja letzte nacht
015 und nicht nächste nacht 015 was es eigentlich sein müsste also nächster tag deswegen guckt
er wenn das datum was man setzen will in der vergangenheit liegt dann macht er das
gleiche datum aber für nächsten tag so und das finde ich ist an der stelle ganz sinnig
so zu haben das ist 6 header check genau so end time brauchen wir da noch genau start
time äh nee duration ist die end time und wenn nächster tag neuer ist wieso passt doch
das kann der händel das kann der händel wenn du es am 31 macht das das das das checkt
er dann zählt er auch das jahr hoch das checkt er soll jetzt legt er hier die silence an
gut silence anlegen brauchen wir noch eine methode in unserer alert manager api klasse
ok cutten wir das mal so nicht nicht delete silence sondern nennen wir es mal post silence
und da kopieren wir mal diesen ganzen crap rein weil ich mir noch angucken muss was wir
genau machen müssen also was brauchen wir denn erstmal das hier aus kommentieren und
gucken was wir alles brauchen silence brauchen wir den hostname ok also hostname start time
end time der autor und ein comment so können wir doch eigentlich alles so lassen soweit
comment ja genau jason jason marschall gucken ob das noch passt was ich da gebaut habe
jason marschall silence post ja moment nee das ist noch hardcoded das funktioniert natürlich
an der stelle so auf gar keinen fall ja es ist ja noch hardcoded so also nicht hardcoded
sondern wie muss man den krempel machen hier oben haben wir es doch muss ich das muss ich
das wieder so machen ok ich muss es wieder ich muss es wieder unnötig kompliziert machen
weil weil gold standard library also client request method ist diesmal post wollen post
request machen url so silences passt achso nee wir wollen was posten wie mache ich denn
ein poster mit jetzt body ja genau war jetzt so ja alles klar und dann sage ich response
gleich client do request gut hat der chat erfahrung mit docker und zeitzone wie kann
er am besten die zeitzone wechseln du kannst environment variable angeben meistens für
zeitzone docker kram wir returnen übrigens bei post silence die id von dieser silence
id so und wenn der kram den ich das letzte mal gemacht habe funktioniert dann sollte
er hoffentlich auch heute noch funktionieren ich kann jetzt silences anlegen also lass
mal überlegen end time da machen wir jetzt folgendes silence id wobei nicht alert mannager
api post silence so hostname start time end time user und comment nee wie habe ich das
comment message nicht message message heißt das ok jetzt sollte eine silence anlegen silence
id sollte ich zurückbekommen wenns funktioniert hat so ok dann copy paste ich den kram von
gestern und dann haben wir moment ansie konsole nee das ist nicht so ganz richtig was da steht
kann man hier 25 stunden als duration angeben ja das geht probieren wir gleich aus erinnere
mich dran sollte funktionieren das probieren gleich aus monitoring silence created silence
id und dann die rakete ganz wichtig wir sind wir sind agil da muss die rakete muss schon
rein so silence starts in bla lassen wir mal weg gucken wir mal ob es prinzipiell funktioniert
also er sollte jetzt wenn das alles funktioniert ohne parameter eines silence anlegen von jetzt
bis 15 minuten schauen wir mal ob das funktioniert hat wobei wir können doch uns selbst listen
das ist schon mal nicht gut der sollte die jetzt auch schon finden wenn ich die angelegt
hab es ist keine silence active stimmt id ist leer der hat die gar nicht angelegt warum
was ist da schon wieder los was was soll das warum hat er die nicht angelegt
was hat er was hat er für probleme ich muss mal kurz in die swagger doku gucken ob man
es überhaupt so macht ja post silence das ist richtig du requests schau mal mal unsupported
mediatype ja ja ja ja ja mediatype header also so request header add bam funktioniert
easy minus l jawoll zeigt er auch an minus c clear minus l nichts mehr da wunderbar klappt
so jetzt müssen wir natürlich auch ein paar status sachen anzeigen dass das ein bisschen
ein bisschen mehr darüber weiß also start in was ist keck minutes was ist was ist keck
keck minutes habt ihr habt ihr irgendein plan was das mal gewesen ist gestern in der duration
müsste das sein irgendeine duration also ne duration keck minutes ja weiß man ich benenne
meine variablen immer so vorzüglich dass man sofort bescheid weiß was mal was gewesen
ist ja seile 132 a ja start time minus sub time now ah dann ist das sowas wie duration
until start oder sowas in der richtung ist das dann ok start time sub now rounden wir
mal wieder auf time seconds dann ist das dann ist das sowas hier ja string oh wat ne moment
was mach ich denn da nutzen starts in null sekunden ok da machen wir jetzt noch ein
bisschen wir sorgen dafür dass es noch ein bisschen schöner ist wir sagen jetzt einfach
if duration until start ist kleiner gleich null ich weiß nicht ob es einen fall gibt
wo es kleine null sein könnte aber wenn es kleiner gleich null ist dann sagen wir duration
until start ist now ach ne moment das eine ist ja keine ahnung start text gleich duration
string und ansonsten now so now starts in now ok also start in doppelpunkt now ja start
now ne aber start in now ist auch durf start start now sowas so ich glaube besser so jetzt
machen wir das noch ein bisschen farbig und zwar habe ich das gesehen das kann mit pterm
machen dann kann man so sagen pterm red ist der text dann rot viel besser aber leute rot
allein tut kattet es nicht es muss rot bold und underline und und andere und unterstrichen
sein drunter mache ich es nicht bold ne ok wie macht man das jetzt bold ok pterm bold
muss ich mir angucken blinkend sehr gute idee blink blink blink wie macht man blink blink
pterm gibt es sowas wie blink blink jawoll ich bin mir nur nicht ganz sicher wie ich
das wie ich das ausgebe ich brauche mal ein paar examples davon easy to use colors pterm
utils pack ne colors ja sowas da im prinzip alter das ist ja mal die hässlichste terminal
library von der formatierung die ich je gesehen habe bg term bg s print moment muss ich sowas
machen blink s s print und und und dann start text funktioniert so das heißt wenn ich das
jetzt bold und underline machen will muss ich dann allen ernstes sowas hier machen bold
s print das ist ja nesting hell das wird ja dann pterm fg red s print das kann so nicht
gedacht sein oder ne oder das kann so nicht gedacht sein pterm underscore s print ne leute
sagt mir wie es anders geht das kann so nicht gedacht sein guckt euch das mal an das ist
doch massif hyper keck ist das aber es funktioniert
das muss schneller blinken ich glaube die blink geschwindigkeit kann man in der shell
nicht angeben es gibt fast blink wirklich fast fast blink ist aber kein unterschied
oder es ist kein unterschied das muss glaube ich das terminal unterstützen
ich glaube dass das muss muss die shell unterstützen
aber banana split schön ist es auch nicht oder so jetzt testen wir mal was ist was ist
wenn ich sage start time start time ist um 23 30 das stimmt ja schon mal nett er startet
nicht genau siehst du schon mal schon mal ein nicer back start time wir haben den back
time wir haben den back time wir haben die back time das ist keinprint glass es ist ein
Now year, now month, now day.
PTM new style.
Okay.
Zeig mal her.
Style.
Okay und dann anstatt diesem hässlichen Krämpel hier, Style, ah okay, okay ja, das ist tatsächlich
ein bisschen besser.
Okay, bold, fg red, underscore, ja das ist schon, das ist schon besser so, ja ja.
Aber trotzdem ist es irgendein Bug in der, in der, in der, in der Timelibrary, Moment,
warum ist Starttime, warum hat Starttime keine, ja Blinken, das ist nicht so wirklich wichtig,
kein Datum gesetzt, ich mach das doch da oben explizit, PTM blink, so wunderbar, ich sag
doch hier explizit Starttime, das Jahr, den Monat und den Tag von Now.
Was steht denn in Now?
Was steht denn in Now drin, ach, wait a minute, wait, wait a minute, ich, ich übergebe da
Müll oder?
Wartet mal Leute, ich mach da, ich mach da, ich mach da Mist, das kann sogar nicht funktionieren.
Nao TS Value, ah das wird überschrieben, das wird überschrieb, ah okay, nee, nee, das ist
nicht die kleine, kleine Nullzeile, das ist das hier, das wird überschrieben, ach hier,
FMT Print TS Nao TS, ja da ist nur die Zeit drinne, Value, da ist nur die Zeit, da ist
nicht, ahja, ahja, okay, okay, das ist natürlich, das ist natürlich pepega, das muss ich fixen,
das kann so nicht funktionieren, ja, also Nao, Time Nao und nicht Nao TS, das ist, das
braucht man nur für, das muss ich vielleicht ein bisschen was besseres überlegen, Nao,
aber jetzt funktioniert meine Logik nicht mehr, jetzt startet es in 2 Stunden 24, okay,
das ist okay, aber jetzt wird das hier nicht mehr funktionieren, jetzt startet es in 24
Stunden, ah fuck, weil er nach before guckt, guck mal da, ja das ist natürlich doof, der
guckt hier ist das, ist diese Zeit davor und das ist sie ja, weil es sind ein paar Nanosekunden
vergangen von einem Befehl zum anderen, okay, das ist wirklich, das ist richtig, richtig
pepega Kram, ja dann muss ich mir das anderweitig speichern, dann muss ich das so machen, dann,
oh ich hab das falsch rum sortiert, ich blicke da nicht mehr durch, dann muss ich das Nao
tatsächlich nicht hier zuweisen, sondern hier und wir usen das dann hier als Default Value,
jetzt sollte es funktionieren, Nao, so 23.30 Uhr, 2 Stunden 22.50 Uhr, jawoll, jetzt funktioniert
es, progge, so, listen wir mal, sollte auch alles klappen, jawoll, alles auflisten, Time
left und die anderen sind pending, die starten erst 23.30 Uhr oder morgen 21 Uhr, so wir
können alle löschen, progge alle gelöscht, funktioniert auch, ich würde fast sagen wir
haben es mehr oder weniger, also ein paar Ausgaben fehlen auf jeden Fall noch, stimmt ja und
hier, progge, Duration größer 24, ja das können wir ausprobieren, Duration 31 Stunden,
wie pass hour, warum kann die Duration nicht größer 24 Stunden sein,
Invalid Value, lass mich raten 23 geht, nee geht auch nicht, ach ich muss glaube ich,
ich muss glaube ich so eingeben, 31 Stunden, ich glaube das ist die Go-Syntax, ist so,
hat funktioniert, Start Now, Duration 31 Stunden, ja 31 Stunden Duration, das funktioniert,
Time left 30 Stunden 59 Minuten 49 Sekunden, ok unsere QuickMuffs funktioniert aber, kann
GoLand Test automatisch generieren, keine Ahnung, aber ich werde dafür keine Tests erstellen,
wobei es ohne Scheiß, es wäre gar nicht blöd dafür Tests zu erstellen, das gucken wir
uns vielleicht mal angucken, das wäre gar nicht blöd an der Stelle, weil es gibt schon
so ein paar Sonderfälle die wir testen sollten, so geht die Duration, clear der alles, listet
der Testweise alles, ja vielleicht sollten wir dafür wirklich ein paar Tests erstellen,
ich glaube das wäre gar nicht so blöd, so also was müssen wir noch ausgeben, Start
müssen wir ausgeben, ach so wisst ihr was wir noch machen könnten, wir könnten gucken,
wir machen das so, Style, der normale Style ist einfach Bold, Red, Underscore und der
Style für Now ist Bold, Underscore und Blink, also sprich, wenn ich jetzt was starte was
jetzt gleich anfängt dann sieht das so aus und wenn ich was um 22 Uhr starten lasse dann
blinkt es nicht, wenn es blinkt es wirkt so, so Achtung es geht los, oder kann man das
vielleicht anhängen, ne Sevenhead, ne kann man wahrscheinlich nicht anhängen, in.net
hätte ich jetzt sowas erwartet und dann irgendeinen Flag anhängen aber geht nicht, Style-Ed gibt
sowas, ach tatsächlich, damit hätte ich jetzt wirklich nicht gerechnet, dass sich
jemand was gedacht hat bei so, das geht natürlich nicht, ach man kann Style an Styles anhängen
was auch immer, wir lassen es, wir lassen es so, keine Fivehead Library hat nicht funktioniert,
lassen wir es, lassen wir es so, ok Startzeit wird angezeigt, dann brauchen wir noch Duration,
das ist dann relativ simpel, Duration ist im Prinzip einfach nur Duration String, Comment
brauchen wir noch, Comment ist Message, das ist bescheuert, dass ich das unterschiedlich
genannt habe, obwohl es das gleiche ist, dann brauchen wir noch den Autor, User, ist dumm,
dass ich die Sachen unterschiedlich genannt habe, so, also wenn ich das jetzt anlege,
dann sieht das, oh Moment hier fehlt, hier fehlt irgendwo, kann auch ein Printl sein
und kein Printf, so jetzt mal Vergleich, so das ist die Go-Variante und das ist die.net
Variante, ich würde mal sagen, was das angeht Mission Accomplished, das ist mehr oder weniger
identisch oder den anderen Cramp hier unten können wir wegmachen, noch ein, noch ein Printline
unten drunter, so wo, wo gebe ich, wo habe ich Pogu ausgegeben, so da geben wir nicht
Pogu aus, sondern irgendwas sinnvolles, ne Leute, ich brauche, ich brauche Englisch Skills,
F, F being removed, ich brauche 5 fette Englisch Skills, dass ich das besser anhört, so minus
C, ah Moment, minus, minus, Punkt, äh, wait a minute, minus C, all silences set by this
program, that's why I've been removed, das klingt, klingt bescheuert, aber ok, das ist,
die Meldung stimmt ja nicht so, no matching silences found, wunderbar, China-Chinesen
everywhere, was ist hier mit Silences gemeint, das hier, der Prometheus Alert Manager, das
ist ein Monitoring System, was deine Server überwacht und wenn du eine Silences einträgst,
dann kannst du den Server ausschalten beispielsweise und solange die Silences aktiv ist, benachrichtigt
dir niemand und dafür ist das Tool auch gedacht, stell dir vor, du bist Admin, hast Wartungsarbeiten
nachts, gehst auf das System, machst Wartungsarbeiten, hast vergessen das Monitoring zu deaktivieren
für das System und der Vorstand kriegt eine SMS geschickt, weil irgendein wichtiges System
angeblich down ist, das willst du ja nicht, deswegen musst du das Silences vorher eintragen
und nachdem die Leute immer so faul sind, habe ich mir gedacht, ein Tool, wo man Silences
direkt vom Server aussetzen kann, wäre schon praktisch, ja, das funktioniert, Leute, heute
haben wir wirklich Progress gemacht, würde ich sagen, wie viele Zeilen haben wir denn,
212 Zeilen, joa, lasst es mir gefallen, ich glaube wir haben auch nichts vergessen, großartig,
Tests können wir als nächstes mal machen, mit Go ein bisschen testen, bisschen zu Tests
beschäftigen, sicherlich nicht verkehrt, das hier hat 109 Zeilen, das ist der Alertmanager,
der ist ein bisschen pepo fett, oder, ah gut, aber so ist es halt, also 300 Zeilen würde
ich mal sagen, so insgesamt zu 330 Zeilen, kann man das nicht anders nennen, mal Refactoring,
was F2, nee, Moment, was war das Refactoring Menü nochmal, Shift F6 ist Rename, einfach,
einfach nur ID, und das Ding heißt Shift F6, so, gut, Notifications, ja, nice, ich würde
sagen, das ist jetzt auch relativ fehlerfrei, gut, wir haben Null Error Handling drinne,
also wenn irgendwas nicht da ist, dann kackts ab und keiner weiß warum, such mal nach was,
Machting, nee, hat mich nicht verschrieben, hab das richtig geschrieben, Machting, nee,
Production Ready, jawoll, achso, guck mal, würde ich auf GoLand hören, das sagt mir
auch schon, dass das ein Schreibfehler hat, mach meine Handy nochmal als Error Message
ja ganz bestimmt, dann rufen die mich noch nachts an, wenn was nicht funktioniert, nice,
so mit Zuduf funktioniert es auch vermutlich mal, what, na gut, ja mit Zuduf stimmt der
Auto auch noch, alles gut, hast du Bereitschaftsdienst, nö, also wir müssen ein paar Tests, ähm,
wie würde man einen Test machen in Go, ob es mit Zuduf funktioniert, gar nicht, oder,
das wäre dann eben ein externes Testprojekt, gibt es, gibt es eine gute Möglichkeit zu
testen, ob was mit Zuduf vorher funktioniert, mir würde, mir würde dann wirklich bloß
einfallen, dass das ein extra Satz an Tests ist, ich bin zum größten Teil Homeoffice,
ja, und wisst ihr was ich cool an dieser einen Library finde, die Hilfe ist auch relativ
aussagekräftig, guck mal, die Usage ist bescheuert, die ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, kann man
Usage disablen, die Usage die der anzeigt, stimmt nämlich schlicht und ergreifend nicht,
ist das doch Description, äh, Description, blub, blub, blub, blub, blub, blub, blub,
blub, blub, blub, blub.
Ah da muss was drinstehen usage text
Usage text so einfach so perfekte usage kann man das nicht disablen
Kann man nicht sagen dass der einfach nix was ist flack usage
Ich will ich will das disablen
Was soll ich da großgescheit reinschreiben?
Okay ja usage okay wir machen so set down time
Nur mit dem Unterschied es gibt keine command es gibt keine global options es gibt bloß options
Und Arguments gibt es auch nicht es gibt nur options
So perfekt genau so muss es sein
Moment commands help das funktioniert ernsthaft
Kann man das
Jetzt soll der gar nicht anzeigen
Help heid help perfekt aber wenn ich helb helb heide dann kommt da gar nichts
Ah ja doch jetzt ist die helb weg okay
Er muss minus minus help machen herkel ja okay dann steht dieser blödsinnig da
Command gibt es auch nicht mehr perfekt ja nice cool
So und jetzt machen wir mal ein build
Go build mal gucken wie groß das binary ist
Ja geht doch
Time user bin time minus v das braucht nichts an zeit
Wir können noch debug symbols raus machen falls das go verkraftet strip postchamp go
6,5 mb leute damit können wir leben oder
Schauen wir mal wie lange mein alert manager damit macht guck mal true du
Mal gucken
Ganz schön viel los hier
Aber abbrechen abbrechen
Und jetzt listen und jetzt listen
Ah falsches falsches Fenster
Na ja geht doch
Ist doch okay
Der muss ja auch ordentlich was listen
Ich mein der muss jetzt gerade
2712 12 mal die api abrufen
Ne muss er nicht
Der macht einen api abruf stimmt überhaupt nicht was ich erzähl
Der macht einen api abruf hat dann aber halt 2700 objekte drin die er deserialisieren muss
und dann die tabelle rendern
Das ist halt nicht so krass performant
So dann lassen wir mal alles löschen jetzt
Wie das ging schnell
Easy alles weg das löschen ging deutlich schneller
Du kannst die durations highlighten wenn sie fast abgelaufen sind okay
Also durations machen wir mal zwei minuten
Funktioniert funktioniert echt gut hätte ich nicht gedacht
Kannst du mit open tml ja ich will es jetzt nicht mal kommt das ist ein komando zeilen
tool
Ich sammle da bestimmt keine monka dsg vo daten drinne
Ist sie dort net variante beim rendern schneller
Gute gute frage können wir mal ausprobieren
Time left ja können wir tatsächlich machen
Time left erinnere mich mal gleich dran dass man das mit der dot net variante ausprobieren
Okay time left
Dann dann sagen wir hier style wieder style
So style ist einfach ganz ganz normal ohne alles
If time left total minutes
Ne gibts nicht
Duration
Wie kriege ich den jetzt raus
Achso kleiner time seconds mal 30 oder so
Style
Red underscore so
Und jetzt time left sprintf
Okay zeig mal ja
Funktioniert nicht
Moment
Löst das hier überhaupt aus
Warum ach ich hab das nicht
Lull
Okay duration
30 sekunden
Ja funst
Und das andere duration 5 minuten
Ist normal
Ja nice funst
Mach mal ausrufezeichen heute da steht ne zusammenfassung
Okay ich sollte gucken ob das in dot net schneller rendert
Probieren wir mal aus
Also erste mal
Build
While
Ich lass ihn mal ein bisschen was anlegen
So sollte reichen denke ich
Also 2151 angelegt
So go minus L
Go run minus L
Oh schon ein bisschen was
Ist das Arbeitszeit nee
User bin bin time
Okay wie lang läuft das
Achso ich sollte das vielleicht
Kann ich das irgendwie
Ja 4 sekunden
5 sekunden oder so
Ich müsste eigentlich nur die Ausgabe von diesem Programm heiden
Also quasi sowas hier machen
Ah nee Moment
Wie lass ich den jetzt das gescheit
Ich hab keine Ahnung wie ich den gescheit nur die
Ich bad time die Ausgabe weg haue
Naja gut wir wissen es sind 5 sekunden
Nee im Moment ist doch alles gut
Ist doch alles gut
Passt doch passt doch alles
Passt doch alles doch alles doch alles richtig
Minus V hab ich vergessen
So elapsed wall clock 4 sekunden
So wir machen der 0 das ist nicht am terminal
Wobei nee wir machen kein def 0
Lass uns rendern
Also go braucht ungefähr
4 sekunden wir können das noch mal richtig benchmarken
Hyper
Build
Aber da spielt die startzeit jetzt noch ne rolle das wollen wir ja nicht
Egal pause
Champ
Go
Plus L
So
Dann zeigt mal her was zum
Wo ist das Problem
Wie starte ich denn den benchmark ich dachte
Hier bin ich nicht ganz sicher was er für schmerzen hat aber ok
Was haben wir denn für ein exit code
Es geht auch deutlich zu schnell
Normalerweise müsste ich so doch den kram starten können
Ah nee jetzt legt er noch mal
Weiß nicht was er für schmerzen ist aber egal
Also go braucht ungefähr 4 sekunden 20 oder so
Oder deutlich länger
Hier 10 sekunden brauche ich jetzt auf einmal
MonkaS
Hab ich noch mal mehr angelegt gerade
Oh wir haben jetzt 3000 ich hab nix gesagt
Dauert noch mal länger
Ok jetzt haben wir so ungefähr 10-11 sekunden
Deswegen hätte ich jetzt eigentlich den benchmark gerne gemacht
Dann dann weiß man es relativ relativ genau
Warum ein minus minus hinter meinem Programm
Ah ok das ergibt tatsächlich sinn
Du hast recht ja das ergibt sinn
Das Problem ist
Ich glaube das checkt das wie
Ok ich habe keine Ahnung was er für schmerzen hat
Ehrlich gesagt
Sag mal läuft da im Hintergrund noch was was weiter anlegt
Oder was
Nee der checkt das mit den Parametern nicht
Die ich übergebe
Der checkt das mit den Parametern nicht
Muss man das quoteen
Und das quoteen
Ok das führt er zu oft aus jetzt
Jetzt braucht er 2 Minuten um das ganze vorzubereiten
Keckel alter 40% CPU Last
Also er braucht irgendwas um
Es schwankt es schwankt ein bisschen
Irgendwas um 13 Sekunden aktuell
Um das einmal auszuführen
Ganz schön lang oder
Ja 13 Sekunden komm brechen wir ab
13 Sekunden sollen die dotnet Variante brauchen wie lang
Minus L
Der Startup ist halt oh das geht deutlich schneller
Leute dotnet rennt das deutlich schneller
Trotzdem langsam Startup
Ja deutlich schneller
2,3 Sekunden
Viel viel schneller als die Go Variante
Ja ich würde sagen die Terminal Library scheint nicht so super optimist zu sein
Oder ich machs einfach
Oder ich machs einfach nicht sinnvoll
Ja es kann ja auch sein dass ich das total bescheuert hier rendere
Berechnen für jeden Eintrag noch die Duration
Das stimmt aber das dürfte nicht
Mein 3000 adi Duration berechnen
Das dürfte nicht nennenswert ins Gewicht fallen
Äh ne oder
Achso können wir ausprobieren
Wobei ne hab ich hier hab ich hier
Ahead of time überhaupt drinnen
Ich glaub nicht
Ne können wir jetzt nicht ausprobieren
Ja alles klar also das haben wir drinnen
Post der Post Champion Go
Ich würd sagen das können wir so lassen
Müssen wir jetzt nicht weiter dran rum basteln
Was hat er für Warnings
Zwei Warnings weil
Ne kann mich mal
Ne Rust mach ich heute echt nicht
Und auch die nächsten Tage nicht
Das hat mich ziemlich geärgert wie kompliziert da viele Sachen sind
Ich mein wir könnten noch ein paar Error handling Sachen machen
Also wir könnten zum Beispiel checken ob
Ob Location auslesbar ist und ob Username auslesbar ist und sowas
Aber ich mein man könnte ja man könnte ja quasi sowas hier sagen
If also if Error zum Beispiel
Panic could not read system username oder so
Oder sowas
Aber Error Handling ist für Pessimisten die denken dass der Kram kaputt geht
Ich bin für kein Error Handling
Error Handling ist bloated
Wollen wir nicht
Wenn es keine Fehler gibt braucht man auch kein Error Handling
Dass es nicht auf Shit hab
Tests Chat was ist mit euch los
Zu viel Daily Scrum gemacht gestern oder was
Ich meine ok der Error Check ist tatsächlich nicht so blöd an der Stelle hier
Eigentlich eigentlich müssten wir auch noch checken
Ob der den Hostname auslesen kann
Kann man sowas hier machen
Mal String
Mein Location geh ich jetzt mal von aus dass er das auslesen
Kann man das so wie macht man das am besten
So hier in der Richtung
Postname FQDN gleich
Kann man das so machen
Error
If Error Post FQDN irgendwie so
Kannst du das auf GitHub pushen
Ja aber was wollt ihr damit
Ich meine das kann außer bei uns bei mir auf der Arbeit auf den Systemen keiner wirklich
Gebrauchen das Ding was ich da gestreckt hab
Zumal auch hier aktuell noch Hardcoded meine lokale Alertmanager AP drinsteht
Die muss ja noch austauschen
Das Tool bringt wirklich denke ich keinem was
Ich kann das pushen das ist kein Ding aber ich weiß nicht was man damit anfangen will
Ich hab das in meiner Freizeit gemacht da hat keiner Rechte drauf von der Arbeit
Nur noch in docker packen warum
Warum
Wo ist der Sinn in dem Fall von docker
Ich meine das ist ein Kommando Zeilen Tool was auf alle Server drauf soll
Das muss nicht in docker laufen
Man könnte in docker Build Container machen aber bei Go ist das ja reichlich unsinnig
Das ist ja das Gute
Ist ja gerade das Gute an Go
Dass du deine Beine ruhig überall laufen lassen kannst
Für das Python Programm oder für die.NET Implementierung oder so
Da brauchen wir irgendeinen Build Docker Container dass es noch auf uralt Betriebssystem läuft
aber bei Go nicht
PostChamp as a Service
Das Programm ist dass du
Stell dir vor es ist 23.45 Uhr du bist Admin musst Wartungsarbeiten machen
loggst dich aufm System ein und das System wird überwacht
Wenn das System weg ist kriegt der Vorstand eine SMS geschickt und sagt
Wichtiges System ist weg und du musst das System Rebooten weil Colonel Update
Du sitzt auf der Kommando Zeile und sagst um 23.29 Uhr Reboot und dann sagst du
Fuck ich hab vergessen eine Maintenance zu setzen
eine Monitoring Silence einzutragen
Und dann hast du kein Bock ins Web Interface zu gehen oder beim 24 7 Support anzurufen
und sagen hier deaktiviert man das Monitoring
Sondern du sagst dann einfach PostChamp und schon hast du eine Monitoring Silence für
15 Minuten eingetragen und kannst deine Wartungsarbeit machen
Und dann gehst du daheim
Wo wird denn noch dieser Müll ausgegeben von der von der Zeit
Hier Star Time weg Bild
Jawoll äh wie kann ich ich mal Bild
Golang Binary Size Reduce was kann man da noch machen
Shrinking your Binary Mit diesem verwirrenden Trick oder mit diesem
komischen Trick Na da bin ich ja mal gespannt
Was soll man machen
LD Flex minus S minus W das trippt einfach nur die Debug Symbols weg
Genauso wie ich eben von Hand gemacht hab
Ja 6,5 MB das ist genau das gleiche
Nein UPX verwende ich ganz bestimmt nicht Wenn ich UPX verwende dann wisst ihr was
das erste ist Chat ratet mal was ist das erste was passiert
Wenn ich das mit UPX packagen würde Das ist das allererste beim drauf kopieren
Der Windows Defender würde sagen Genau der Windows Defender wir haben ja mittlerweile
auf allen unsere Linux Servern Leider also ich kümmere mich ja nur nur um Linux Systeme
Wir haben Windows Defender auf allen unsere Linux Server mittlerweile drauf
Kein Spaß ist echt so ok Microsoft Microsoft Advanced Threat Protection
ist aber es ist der Windows Defender der Password Leaker genau und sobald ich das da drauf kopiere
sagt der Windows Defender Achtung Virus wenn ich das mit UPX pange
Da bin ich mir relativ sicher Ich weiß wir können es mal ausprobieren
Ja nur mal ich kann euch das mal zeigen UPX ist an sich wirklich was cooles
Das ist ein Package Programm das komprimiert die Binary Programme in quasi so eine Art
Self Extracting Zip nenne ich das jetzt mal Das ist das ist tatsächlich ganz cool
Wie geht das UPX best oder so Best
Ja dann probieren wir das mal aus oder soll ich soll ich auch noch ultra ultra ultra Brut
ultra Brut machen wir jetzt Strip Pause Champ Go
Das wird aber dadurch die dadurch wird aber die Startup Zeit langsamer ist ja klar da
muss es erstmal extrahieren wieder Das dauert jetzt der macht 17 Durchläufe
Das ist ziemlich langsam wenn man die die extreme Variante am Ende ist das Binary vielleicht
noch zwei MB oder so das lohnt sich nicht wirklich
ultra
Achja Mods und und YouTube Uploader den den ersten Stream von heute Abend nicht hochladen
es ist nicht schlimm wenn ich E-Mail Adressen liege aber ich will die nicht für die Nachwelt
überall sichtbar haben Wenn man es gesehen hat ist nicht weiter wild
aber nicht hochladen Mitbekommen
Ne das war auch das war blöd ich wusste nicht dass er da dass er dabei steht also Leute
ich hab den ich hab den Stream von vorhin auch schon gelöscht
So also es ist durch 2 MB haben wir jetzt fast fast ein C Programm allerdings guckt mal
die Ausführgeschwindigkeit ist merkt ihr das ist eine ganze Ecke langsamer als vorher
nicht nicht so krass schlimm aber ist schon ist schon eine Ecke langsamer
also die Startup Performance der Rest ist egal
Also bei 400 noch was ist Go noch schnell
Serious Max könntest du weil ich weiß nicht wie lange ich noch da bin könntest du im
Mod Channel im Discord sagen dass die nicht den Stream hochladen sollen wo ich vorhin
meine E-Mail Adresse geleakt habe
Ich hab den auch schon gelöscht also der ist eh weg wenn die noch nicht runtergeladen
haben also nicht auf YouTube hochladen und nicht ins Archiv also nicht den hier sondern
den direkt davor da wo es dann so rumgeleckt hat den hab ich auch eh schon gelöscht
Wie gesagt nichts Schlimmes aber ich will es nicht in der Welt verteilen
Guck mal hier die Anzeige mit läuft bald ab funktioniert
Wisst ihr was wir jetzt noch bräuchte man bräuchte jetzt noch Minus Minus Watch Leute
das wäre die High IQ Variante Minus Minus Watch dass man das in einem T-Max Fenster
auf hat und dann permanent so sieht aha wie viel Zeit hab ich noch wie viel Wartungsarbeiten
Zeit hab ich noch
Das wärs oder P-Term kann ja Watch echt P-Term Watch
Was darf ich mir darunter vorstellen wie soll das Watch
Wisst ihr jetzt nicht was das mit P-Term zu tun hat
Also dass wir noch sowas hier einbauen
Watch und das einzige was bei Watch passiert das ist tatsächlich relativ easy relativ easy
zu machen ja Watch würden wir einfach an der Stelle gucken
Watch Einfach Endlosschleife 4 ne wie macht man eine Endlosschleife 4 true ne why go lang
Endlosschleife infinite loop einfach nur 4
Der Pause Jam wird nicht Pause Jam also er wird set down time heißen
4 das ist einfach print silence gibt es sowas wie ein sleep
time sleep duration time sleep seconds mal ne Sekunde können wir sleepen
Was ist das Problem wieder irgendein Error den wir ignorieren müssen ne
Was hat er für Schmerzen ach ich mach return ich will nicht return
So Minusminuswatch ach ne run
Minusminuswatch erstmal erstmal clearn erstmal clearn das ist sinnvoll da was da steht
So und jetzt und jetzt duration ne und jetzt paar mal anlegen noch
Und jetzt minusminuswatch da guck mal an wobei das ist nicht gut das soll sich überschreiben
das muss clearn und dann und dann so ist das doof so ist das doof ich brauch ich brauch
ein clear
So ein clear screen terminal
Thunders Pterm clear screen ah wir haben eine Demo
Ah read was ne area könntet ihr also wenn ihr wollt kann ich
das pushen aber ich glaube nicht dass man dieses Programm sinnvoll verwenden kann ohne
Modifikationen also ich kann das pushen pushen wir können das nächste stream pushen also
wenn es euch was bringt klar warum nicht aber ich kann mir halt nicht vorstellen das
ist großartig ja guck mal hier so so macht man das
Also area start und dann sleep seconds
Keine endlosschleife keckel alter können wir uns das stopp auch sparen
Was machen die denn hier kann man da kein newline drinne machen
New letter from string s render default big text ne das will ich wahrscheinlich nicht
haben ich will einfach nur print oder
ne das funktioniert so nicht ich ich mach dir sprint ja in einer in einer
Funktion und gib nicht irgendwie den text zurück ne ne das das das funktioniert nicht
es wird da müsste ich das ganze ding anders anders bauen was ist das ok ich machs nochmal
rückgängig ein kram hier so und jetzt sagen wir clear screen danach
guck aufs jetzt funst naja ok schön ist was anderes schön ist
schön ist echt was anderes es flimmert es flimmert schon flimmert schon ganz schön
ne also ich mein so als funktioniert auch nicht in jedem emulator ja das stimmt
ich mein ok besser als nix so jetzt kann man jetzt kann man watchen wie das wie das runter
zählt wenn man das wenn man das wirklich sinnvoll implementieren will gerade auch hier vielleicht
mit diesem area printer und sowas dann müsste man das tatsächlich dann müsste man das anders
machen und zwar da dürfte das nicht print print silence heißen sondern irgendwie keine
ahnung get string print silence oder so mit fünf sekunden das geflimmere ist immer das
geflimmere ist immer doof dinox fast clear screen ja das mache ich ja gerade schon ne
das müsste man das müsste man wirklich anders machen dass er nicht den den den screen cleart
sondern dass das immer überschreibt also da mache ich mir da mache ich mir anderweitig
mal Gedanken drüber so kann ich damit erstmal leben ja und dann machen wir es jetzt runter
auf einmal in der sekunde dann flimmert zwar aber das flimmern hast du bei allem wo du
clear screen machst normalerweise musst du ja bei sowas nicht nicht screen clearn sondern
überschreibst die zeilen quasi wieder genau das das müsste man hiermit machen aber ich
habe halt das hier nicht als text sondern das macht schon die ausgabe das das reicht
jetzt erstmal jaja area macht das aber ich kann area nicht verwenden weil der eigentliche
text der kommt ja hierher und der ich mein ich mein was ich machen könnte wäre wahrscheinlich
anstatt die tabelle hier zu rendern ich mein anstatt die tabelle hier zu rendern könnte
ich sagen irgendwie get silence silence table oder so und dann geben wir zurück eine was
eine p-term table table printer und den könnte ich dann da rendern im in der area nähe aber
das ist kacke da muss ich das umstricken da habe ich auch kein bock drauf in der area
bringt das nix dass das versteht ihr falsch du musst den text geben den das dann da reinschreibt
und wenn ich eine funktion habe die ich aufrufe die selber auf die konsole schreibt dann funktioniert
das nicht dieses area render ding hier muss das handeln mit dem string kann ich einfach
auf die konsole schreiben und an die area verwenden dass das funktioniert nicht ich bräuchte
ich meine ich kann euch zeigen dass es prinzipiell funktioniert und das mal wieder rein so und
jetzt führe ich einfach mal das da aus watch guck das refreshed ohne irgendwelches geflimmer
weil es refreshed wirklich nur das was sich geändert hat das heißt ich kann jetzt halt
nicht die die sache aus ausgeben da drin sondern müsste mir den string zurückgeben lassen also
halt nicht so nicht so nice müsste ich ja quasi das da rausnehmen sondern es render
kann das kommt dann da ein string raus bei ja das kann ich machen hier string das das
würde funktionieren das return wir keinen error sondern ein string ne go pass hat glaube
ich keiner gecheckt go pass go pass ist bloated
so und jetzt können wir hier sagen wind silences so jetzt sollte das funktionen was ist das
problem was hat jetzt ach so ja ja so komm egal brauche ich jetzt funktioniert das leute
jetzt flimmert da auch nichts mehr aber jetzt haben wir es eigentlich nur unnötig kompliziert
gemacht ne center wollen wir da nix
jetzt aktualisiert er jede sekunde kannst du bei zugucken wie er updatet
und abbrechen geht auch wobei man es dann halt eigentlich nicht print silences nennen
dürfte sondern generate silences table oder so ja dann dann passt es wieder ein bisschen
besser und ich darf dann auch nicht sagen hier drin
no matching silences found sondern ich müsste dann sagen return no matching silences found
weil wenn er nix findet wo ist das problem achso ja aber wenn er nix findet haben wir
mal so löschen löschen wir mal alles und dann sagen wir minus minus watch so not found
minus l funktioniert auch so was jetzt natürlich cool ist guckt mal was man jetzt machen kann
ist wenn ich jetzt doppelt starte und leg jetzt welche an dann erscheinen die auf der linken
seite gleich guckt bamm das ist das massive ausrufe zeichen heute ist es jetzt kann ich
hier unten welche anlegen kannst du live zugucken wie es geedet wird und wenn man jetzt so was
sagen könnte wie duration 10 sekunden dann taucht die auch in rot drauf auf und läuft
dann gleich ab kann ich verkaufen genau huge money
es hat einen was für den approach ein holistik approach was soll denn das bedeuten ich weiß
gar nicht was das wort bedeutet ganz einheitlichen ah ja ob wir es feifert wort richtiges feifert
wort wie ist heute deine meinung zu go ich finde es immer noch undurchdacht an vielen
stellen und die standard library ist auch wohl obwohl die so super gelobt wird an vielen
stellen irgendwie lückenhaft ja aber wir haben was sinnvolles mit hingekriegt wir sind auch
fertig mehr oder weniger würde ich sagen aber das finde ich cool mit diesem automatisch
das war eine gute chat wer hatte die idee ich glaube ich glaube ich hatte die idee der chat
hat mich nur auf die idee gebracht ist gar nicht einfach dafür gedacht nö für rest service
ist nö nicht zwangsläufig da ist eigentlich mal als einsteiger einfach zu lernende sprache
gedacht gewesen aber ich finde weder die sündung sonderlich einfach noch die standard library
sonderlich komplett ich weiß ich was mich als einzige was mich an go überzeugt ist die
static binaries bei was genau lückenhaft zum beispiel dass es kein url punkt join gibt
ok das gibt es jetzt mit go 1.19 bald oder dass es kein http punkt delete oder kein http
punkt putt gibt sondern nur get und post
was braucht länger in dort net oder dort net ist viel schneller gewesen in unserem test
jetzt mit diesem programm das liegt aber an der tabellen render library also wir haben
3000 einträge gemacht haben die rendern lassen im terminal was komplett auf schwachsinn ist
ergibt ja keinen sinn dass da 3000 monitoring silences eingetragen sind also go hat 13
sekunden gebraucht und und das dort net program hat es in ja irgendwie zweieinhalb gerendert
aber das kein sinniger vergleich gewesen ja nein das ist einfach nur ein string wo
drinne steht putt das ist nicht das ist nicht die funktion zum input ein putt absetzen
mit http könnte man auch aber nicht so schön du hast ja aber nicht so schön also man könnte
auch so machen ja das stimmt watch minus er kann color minus z ja aber das ist das ist
nicht so schön wie eingebautes watch gehen tut das auch aber eingebautes watch ist mehr
pock
die umsetzung na die umsetzung ist in dort net viel viel in c sharp viel schneller gewesen
für mich als in go also in go habe ich jetzt ja mehrere streams stundenlang darum gebastelt
gut ich hatte auch keine ahnung von go mittlerweile habe ich doch schon ein bisschen besseren
durchblick man hat es heute glaube ich auch gemerkt so ein paar sachen habe ich mittlerweile
schon geschnallt wie es funktioniert für mich war das in c sharp zu programmieren deutlich
nerven schonender angenehmer und schneller aber das liegt zum größten teil daran weil
ich c sharp deutlich mehr gewohnt bin als go auf der anderen seite bin ich immer noch
der meinung dass es die beste beste sprache und das beste framework ist was es so gibt
zum entwickeln für fast alles nicht für alles aber für fast alles nein in c plus plus
werden wir das nicht machen sage ich euch gleich allein schon ein web request in c plus plus
zu machen ist doch komplette zumutung da habe ich auch anfälle gekriegt mit der zeit guckt
euch das an ja sieht erstmal lesbar aus aber diese magic zahlen machen mich verrückt woher
soll man wissen dass 0 2.01.0 2006 dass das so die formatierung ist also dann ist es mir
lieber die klassische sache mit dd mm und sowas ss gibt es dann sonst noch months months
in groß das ist das ist das ist besser als als hier diese komischen zahlen ne ne du musst
nicht das datum eintragen in go ist es so dass das da 0 2 ist ein magic wert für ähm
bei anderen programmiersprachen ist es dd also das ist das gleiche wenn da 0 2 steht
weiß go dass man an dieser stelle den tag haben will das ist magic magic deswegen steht
ja auch 2006 da warum warum auch immer also mit mit 15 weiß go damit ist die stunde gemeint
und mit 04 mal weiß go damit muss die minute gemeint sein und sowas also es ist schon ein
bisschen pence champ ne ne das ist kein beispiel das muss go so haben deswegen steht es ja
auch zweimal unten drunter weil du musst das so machen wenn ich hier drei hinschreibe
an der stelle dann denkt go das ist keine ahnung das ja in kurzschreibweise oder so
was auch immer für was auch immer drei steht ne ne das ist das ist sehr wir das finde ich
auch eklig was ich auch eklig finde ist diese append geschichte hier na aber wir haben es
jetzt hinbekommen wunderbar funst alles pork chat wisst ihr was ich jetzt mache ihr kommt
nie drauf das sage ichs wieder alter das würde ich bestimmt nicht so ankündigen hier im
chat ne ich gehe jetzt pennen und vorher und vorher mache ich das hier und vorher mache
ich pepo toilet zoom der chat wieder so chat schön dass ihr dabei gewesen seid hat ja
alles funktioniert haben wir sehr viel progress gemacht heute und jetzt gehe ich auf bis
dann machts gut zu